Cédricou, bonsoir.
Arrête. [rires]
Donc on a [grognement] eu un petit
problème de son pour le premier
démarrage. On s'excuse infiniment. On a
une mise à jour célérate.
Bonsoir Cédric et Rou. Nous vous
recevons [rires]
pour une chaîne YouTube qui s'appelle
Serview. Nous sommes en direct. Arrêtez
conneries. Est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement en faisant vibrer
vos cordes vocales ? Arrête. [rires]
Bonsoir, je m'appelle Ça marche là ?
[__] c'est magnifique. Donc, je suis
Cédric Erou, je suis agriculteur,
délinquant pour d'autres,
humaniste pour d'autres aussi et voilà.
Bah, je suis paysan avant tout, je
pense, hein. Paysan de la veille de la
Roya. une vallée qui est
franco-italienne, une vallée qui a
Ouais. une vallée, une vallée quoi où
bah ses voisins bah c'est pas c'est pas
le pays étranger, c'est les Italiens.
Les Italiens, les voisins c'est les
Français. Puis on vient ensemble, on
boit la même eu, on cultive les mêmes
arbres, on a la même agriculture et
[raclement de gorge] et puis voilà quoi.
C'est quoi agriculteur au 21e siècle ?
Non, pas agriculteur, on est paysan en
fait. Et
paysan, c'est un mec qui euh qui euh qui
a envie de vivre sur son son lieu de vie
et qui ouvre sa porte et qui regarde ce
qu'il y a devant lui et voir ce qu'il
peut faire pour gagner à ses tunes pour
pour continuer à vivre. Et nous, ce
qu'on a en ouvre notre porte, c'est de
la terre. Donc, on cultive la terre pour
euh pour nous avant tout. Et ça, la
différence entre agriculteur et paysan,
c'est que le paysan, il va il va vivre
pour lui et le surplu, il va le vendre.
Et l'agriculteur, lui, c'est un métier,
c'est une voilà, il va il va il va
travailler pour les autres quoi. Nous,
on est plus dans un truc où on essaie de
vivre tranquille dans notre petit lieu,
dans notre petit monde et voilà ce que
c'est qu'un paysan.
Je vais vous poser la question que tout
le monde vous a posé. Qu'est-ce qui vous
a conduit à ramasser des moues sur le
bord de la route ? Bah c'est qu'ils
étaient sur le bord de la route. C'est
que à un moment à Paris euh des hommes
grill en cravat euh souvent assez vieux
ont décidé de de refermer la la la
frontière dans l'espace Schengen entre
la France et l'Italie. Nous depuis les
années 85 90, on a pris l'habitude de
passer ses frontières sans y prêter
garde et d'un coup bah des gens sont
restés bloqués et du coup on les a vu
qu'ils étaient bloqués et on a vu des
gamins sur le bord des routes et des
gamins essayaient de détourner des
contrôles policiers et on a vu la force
sentinelle. Vous savez la force
sentinelle c'est les ces militaires qui
sont en en tenue de camouflage mais non
pas pour se camoufler mais pour qu'on
les voit. On les voit partout là en ce
moment. Et et ces gens-là, ces
militaires coursaient des gosses pour
les choper et les ramener à la PAF, donc
la police des airs des frontières pour
les ramener en Italie. et nous on s'est
retrouvé au milieu de tout ça et la
volonté de bah de de préserver notre
intégrité intégrité sur sur le devoir de
bah de d'aider d'aider des personnes qui
étaient bah qui étaient maltraité qui
étaient euh c'est même pas de l'abandon,
j'allais dire abandon mais c'est même
pas ça. C'est pire que ça l'abandon
c'est qu'on regarde plus les gens mais
là c'est pire que ça c'est qu'on les
traque et on s'est dit bah qu'il fallait
agir quoi. Et puis on a et c'est pas un
une militance
pr pro migration pr migrant, c'est c'est
juste de dire tu as des gosses et qui
sont là et tu vas et tu vas tu tu vas
les aider quoi. Donc j'ai ouvert ma
porte à des gamins et à des familles.
C'est c'est quand on dit on c'est qui ?
C'est combien ? C'est c'est à partir de
quelle date ? C'est dans quelle dans
quelle proportion ? Combien
? Le au départ j'en faisais pas partie.
C'est que le a commencé en 2011, si je
m'abuse. C'est pendant qu'il y avait le
printemps arabe et qu'on a eu des
Tunisiens qui ont débarqué. Euh donc le
faisait des marodes à 20000, donc
distribuit de la nourriture à Vimi. Ma
Vimi, c'est à 20 minutes de route de
chez nous. Et moi, je leur filais un peu
des œufs, des trucs, une surpr
surproduction. Et euh et puis après en
2015, il y a une association qui
s'appelle Roya Citoyenne qui est venue
me voir qui m'a dit "Cédric, tu peux pas
sur ta ferme accueillir du monde et
cetera." Et moi je moi j'étais plus dans
le dans le j'étais engagé dans la dans
dans l'associatif mais plus sur d'ordre
culturel. Organiser des concerts, du
théâtre et essayer de de faire venir des
gens de Nice dans la veille de la Roya
et monter des marchés paysans avec des
prétextes. Donc la musique, le théâtre,
la rencontre et cetera. Et j'avais pas
envie de m'engager dans le le le
militantisme parce que je trouve ça
chiant en fait. Tu vois ces réunions
tout le monde se se gueule dessus ou
personne n'est d'accord ou
j'avais pas envie quoi. Donc quand
Suzelle de royal citoyenne m'a dit "Mais
détend de chez toi". Bah j'ai j'ai dit
j'ai dit "Non j'ai dit non, j'ai pas
envie ça me j'ai pas envie de me [__]
là-dedans, quoi."
Et après c'est c'est arrivé quand même à
beaucoup quand même. C'est vous avez
cédé
et après Ouais. Mais après, j'ai eu
différentes c'est venu petit à petit,
quoi. C'est que un jour, j'étais à moto
et euh et euh je passe par euh par par
la côte entre Vimi donc Vimi, c'est en
bas de la de la veille de la Roy en
Italie. Et je vais direction Menton et
euh je passe le donc cette frontière qui
était qui était fermée,
[raclement de gorge] hein, depuis 2015.
Donc là, on est en 2016 et je vois des
des des jeunes blacks que des hommes mis
sur les rochers sur la digue donc la mer
à côté et ces blacks là menac la police
de dire si vous vous approchez nous on
se jette à la mer et on sait pas nager.
Et j'ai été un peu troublé par par tout
ça quoi parce que la migration moi je la
voyais à la télé et ces gens qui fui la
guerre, qui fui la dictature, qui fuit
bah la misère économique et on les a
retrouvé là et moi j'ai eu ce réflexe de
de ça m'a fait peur un peu un peu comme
tout le monde tu sais la migration ça
fait peur à tout le monde et j'ai eu un
peu peur en posant des questions. Je me
dis mais [__] c'est quand même fou
que [grognement] les mecs soient là.
Enfin, tu as la misère chez toi en fait,
tu vois la misère de de du monde en
fait, du monde du monde tu vois du monde
de la planète quoi et qui est là à tes
portes et ça fait flipper quoi parce que
tu te retrouves confronté à une réalité
qui te dépasse qui te dépasse
complètement. Et du coup, je me suis
posé pas mal de questions. Donc Suzelle
de Royal citoyenne est venu me voir me
dire "Ouvre ta ferme pour me détendre."
J'ai dit non. Et puis après, il y a eu
un déclenchement, c'est que en revenant
de de mes livraisons, donc parce que je
suis agriculteur, tous les jeudis je
livre à Nice. Ouais, je suis paysan.
Ouais.
et et je remonte de mes livraisons.
Avant ça, je vais dans un bar très sympa
qui s'appelle le CAD à Nice et on boit
des coup avec les potes et tout. On
refait le monde et puis je remonte et je
suis ma clope au volant entre les jambes
ma bière. C'est pas très bien mais
et je remonte et je pense à autre chose.
Je suis ailleurs et je connais cette
route parfaitement. Ça fait et la route
qui monte de 26000 à Breille, c'est une
route ultra sinueuse. Tu vois, il faut
s'imaginer, c'est une route sans
trottoir, ultra sinueuse dans les Alpes.
Donc le côté droit, tu as la roya en
dessous et le côté gauche, tu as la
falaise, la montagne qui monte et et
puis après dans l'obscurité, j'ai un
véhicule C15 tout pourri qui éclaire mal
et je vois des silhouettes et je fais un
un écart, je mets un coup de volant et
je continue quelques centaines de mètres
et je me dis [__] il y avait un gosse
dedans et tout et je me dis merde et je
fais demi-tour, je prends cette famille
là et ils me disent : "On va aller à
Paris Paris Paris j'ai fait non mais là
c'est B sur Roya et puis la V de la roya
tu as 26 mill tu montes tu as
[grognement]
B sur Roya et après que tu continues tu
arrives tand et derrière Témont donc
l'Italie et c'est vraiment une espèce de
d'enclave en France quoi. Et je dis non
mais là c'est le train. Il fait non donc
station station et je suis bah le train
c'est demain. Donc si avec ta famille
viens viens à la maison et tu dors à la
maison et demain demain je t'emmène je
t'emmène prendre le train et donc on se
couche, je jette un matelas par terre
des couvertures, les gens se couchent,
dorment, on se réveille le matin et je
me dis [__] qu'est-ce que je fous
maintenant avec cette famille là et je
sais qu'il y a des contrôles de police
dans les gares qui vont jusqu'à Nice
tout ça. Bon, ils veulent aller en gare
et et je les amène au train. On
s'échange les numéros de téléphone avec
le papa et il me rappelle et il me dit
qu'il est qu'il s'est fait renvoyer en
Italie et qu'il est dans dans l'église
Saint-Anonio. C'est un curé qui a ouvert
c'est les les portes de son église pour
pour
les familles, pour les femmes isolées,
pour les mineurs isolés. Chaque
chrétienne. Charité chrétienne.
Ouais. la charité, mais un peu plus que
la charité parce que c'est un mec qui
qui a investi. Lui, il était plus lancé
sur la sur une forme de solidarité. Et
je découvre dans cette église donc
une salle de 150 m² avec des lits
superposés, les gens qui tentent des
couvertures pour avoir un peu
d'intimité,
ces gamins qui regardent leurs parents
avec des grands yeux en mode "Bon, on
fait quoi papa ? Maman, où on va ?
Qu'est-ce qu'on fait ?" et les parents
qui peuvent pas décider, qui peuvent pas
décider de quand on part, quand on y va,
qui peut pas décider de qu'est-ce qu'on
mange à midi. Donc c'est des plats qui
sont donnés comme ça aux gens et des
gens qui sont considérés un peu comme
des cartons, tu vois, un peu comme une
espèce de de de marchandise, une
contrefaçon.
Et je me dis tiens, ben il faut il faut
il faut il faut que faut faut que j'aide
ces gens quoi parce que parce que de
voir des gamins dans une situation
pareille, je dis c'est pas possible. Et
surtout, je me sentais par rapport à à
nos voisins, aux Italiens, je me sentais
un peu complice, tu vois. En tant que
français, je me dis "Putain, la France,
elle ferme ses frontières mais elle a
pas demandé quoi que ce soit à l'Italie.
Et en Italie, il y a rien qui est mis en
place pour bah pour gérer un accueil.
Donc il y a pas de centre pour les pour
les pour les pour les personnes en
migration, il y a pas de centre pour les
familles, pour les enfants. Il y a que
cette église qui a ouvert ses portes et
et je me dis ben il faut il faut il faut
les aider quoi.
Donc ça ça a été ton déclic. Euh
au fur et à mesure
le l'arsenal
policier s'est rapproché de de vous.
pas de suite. La police est pas venue de
suite. La police, elle est venue euh
plus tard. C'est en fait je me fais je
me fais arrêter en août 2016. Donc ça
faisait quelques mois que je faisais
passer des gamins et des familles. Et
c'est quel c'est combien
combien de personnes ? J'ai revendiqué
200 personnes mais j'ai exagéré pendant
ma garde à vue parce que mon avocate qui
s'appelle François Scottard et qui donc
je me fais arrêter flagrant des lit avec
des personnes, c'est flagrant le passage
de frontière par la police italienne et
française. Donc une une arrestation un
peu brutale quoi, tu vois. Donc j'étais
dans ma bagnole les sep personnes
derrière les girophares il me serrent la
la voiture contre le le la glissière de
sécurité, je m'arrête.
Ils me sortent, ils me mettent un fling
là. Sors de la bagnole. Sors de la
bagnole.
C'est vrai coup du flingue là.
Ah ou je te jure. Et donc il mettent le
flingue sur la tempé ou je ne sais quoi.
Et je dis non, on a pas d'armes, on a
pas d'armes. Et tout il me sort de la
voiture, il me demande d'ouvrir les
portes arrières donc les gamins qui
gueulent, qui pleurent et tout et euh et
je me retrouve men noter. Moi, j'ai un
problème d'épaule. Je me suis fait opéré
gamin. Enfin, j'ai j'ai le problème de
bras. Ils me mettent les mains derrière
le dos, ça me fracasse l'épaule et euh
et ils me disent "Bah, on va on va
t'emmener à la police et frontière à à
Menton." Et du coup, il trimballe c'est
sep personnes à l'arrière de mon
véhicule qui est vraiment une épave ce
truc. Et je leur dis "Mais vous pouvez
pas prendre un véhicule plus adapté au
transport ?" On me dit "Tu es bien
gentil, tu es bien marrant mais toi ça
t'a pas gêné de les transporter de 26000
jusqu'à chez toi dans cette bagnole
pourrie et là tu nous reproches de de
les transporter dans la même voiture. et
et on arrive, on descend, on traverse
l'Italie, donc on redescend la veille de
la Royale, on arrive à Vintimi, on
rejoint le bord de mer et puis on arrive
à Menton va la Puf et là tu as tu as les
flics qui sont là donc ils sont super
contents parce qu'ils ont chopé un
passeur et cetera et ils prennent des
photos de ces gens qui sont à l'arrière
du véhicule entassés avec les gamins qui
pleurent euh et puis les blagues
racistes fusent regard ça sent la mort
machin
espèce de truc peu au dieu qui qui qui
qui qui se passe comme ça quoi. Et euh
donc du coup je suis mis en garde à vue
et Françoise Gota donc l'avocate arrive
et je dis bon je dis quoi ? Moi c'est ma
première garde à vue, j'avais jamais
fait de garde à vue quoi. Et je dis je
dis quoi ? Et puis il m'a dit soit tu
revendiques ou soit tu fais le neux
quoi. Et je me dis bon revendique, OK.
J'ai revendique, j'ai revendiqué, j'ai
dit 200 personnes mais il y a pas 200
personnes et j'ai dû aider à 30 40
personnes en tout et je fais 48 heures
de garde à vue et à cette époque-là,
j'étais pas du tout médiatisé et et le
procureur de la République me fait
bénéficier de l'immunité humanitaire et
il dit "C'est vrai que les conditions
d'hébergement
à à Vinimi sont indignes et c'est vrai
qu'il y a une nécessité d'agir. Donc
immunité humanitaire, je ressors de là,
tu vois, c'est quand même
comment dire une bataille gagnée quoi.
Et à tout à tous les les réseaux
militants qui ment voir [__]
l'immunité humanitaire et tout machin,
c'est génial. Enfin, la justice
accepte et et considère le le le le côté
négatifs de la fermeture des frontières.
Et on a été entendu. Et Hubert Jourdan.
Ber Jordan, c'est un mec qui est devenu
un ami. C'est un mec qui a une
soixantaine d'années qui a été euh
salarié pour gérer des camps
humanitaires un peu partout dans le
monde pour des crises de je sais pas de
migration ou de trembement de terre ou
de machin. Lui, il montait des camps
humanitaires et chez lui dans sa petite
maison, ben il a il héberge depuis des
décennies quoi. Et il me dit là, tu as
un rôle à faire, c'est de médiatiser. Il
faut que tu médiatises. Il faut que
maintenant la justice a compris le
désarroit de ces personnes et il faut
ton rôle c'est de médiatiser et moi
médiatisé par la publique et tout je oh
là c'est pas mon truc qu'est-ce que je
vais leur dire ? Comment je vais gérer
tout ça ? et je me lance là-dedans.
Donc, j'accepte
les médias chez moi. Et et dans un qui a
quand même fait pas mal de bruit, c'est
Adame Nosit de du New York Times qui
vient à la maison et donc le mec, c'est
un américain qui vient, moi je parle pas
anglais en fait, pas du tout et on a du
mal un peu à se comprendre. Il parle
français et je lui dis, je lui parle des
gamins, je lui parle de la reconduction,
je lui parle de la police, tout ça. Et
le mec, il me regarde un peu ébêté.
[__] mais il est tebé ce mec ou quoi ?
Il compr il comprend rien ce que je lui
dis et il me dit Crake je je je voudrais
si ça vous dérange pas de faire venir un
photographe parce que c'est important ce
qui se passe. Je veux rester de tr jour
si ça vous va je veux rester vas-y une
caravane là-bas et tout il y a pas de
problème. Il y a le photographe qui
arrive et c'est Pierre
Turgeman ou je sais plus comment il
s'appelle qui me dit ouais tu sais pas
qui c'est ce journaliste. C'est un grand
journaliste. tu, tu devrais prendre le
prendre un peu au sérieux parce que
c'est vrai que je c'est pas que je
méprisais du tout, c'est pas ça, mais je
le négligeais un peu quoi et euh et je
lui dis à dameur, j'ai fait "Tu veux
voir ce que c'est les gamins, la les
flics, comment ça se passe ?" Je suis
"Ben viens avec moi." Et du coup, je
prends les gamins qui sont qui sont à la
maison. Donc c'est tous des gamins venus
d'érréement
de contrôle policier pour aller jusque
en gare. Et ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que dans la veille de la Roya donc
tu as l'Italie 26000 en bas tu remontes
break sur roya et tu continues, tu
arrives dans le pied monond. Donc c'est
vraiment une enclave et il y a pas de
contrôle policier, il y a pas de il y a
pas de de ouais de contrôle policier
systématique au bord de la route entre
Bre sur Roya et Vimi. Mais les contrôles
policiers systématiques, c'est entre Bre
sur Roya et ce qu'on appelle la vraie
France quoi, le Nice et cetera. Et du
coup, on on part et puis avec une
voiture ouvreuse, on continue poc pc et
les flics là là, on arrive à passer, on
va en garde en type, trop de flics. OK,
bon, on va en garde canne, on arrive en
garde canne et là, tu as des tu as des
vigiles qui sont qui sont à l'entrée et
qui me voi avec
avec des blacks des jeunes blacks et qui
qui téléphone. Je me dis bon, on a
quelques minutes là pour pour agir. Là,
tu as la police for revière qui arrive.
On se prend la tête machin tat taat. Et
tu as le photographe qui dit "Putain, il
y a les flics Cédric, il y a les flics,
bouge bouge, bouge, bouge, il y a les
flics, il y a les flics." Et là, je vois
que bon, c'est grillé. Donc on part en
courant dans la garde de Canne. Et ce
qu'il faut savoir, la garde de Cann
et puis c'est en plein été quoi. Tu
vois, Cann c'est la côte d'Azur quoi. Tu
as tous les touristes qui sont là avec
leur bob Jeune Fluo, leur matelas de
plage, tu vois, ils sont là en vacances
quoi. Et et euh et on part en courant
dans ces marges de marbre blanc et
cetera. nous avec nos godasses de
montagnes pleines de bout et cetera et
on part en fourgon et on et on se bat en
fait, on fait un espèce de de d'élite
suite et et ce ce journaliste du New
York Times hallucine un peu sur sur
comment gérer la migration en France et
enfin surtout la frontière
franco-italienne. Il fait un article de
presse, moi je m'attendais à avoir
uncart comme ça et en fait on fait la
première page. On fait la première page.
À cette époque- làà c'était Vals qui
était ministre de l'intérieur et lui il
pète un plomb quoi. il pète un plomb et
il dit au préfet, il dit au procureur,
lui là vous le vous le coffrez et et
vous et vous l'arrêtez. Mais le problème
c'est qu'ils sont venus trop tard. Ils
sont venus trop tard, c'est que quand
j'ai avant j'is du passage de frontière
et quand le le procureur m'a fait
bénéficier de l'immunité humanitaire et
que je comprends surtout l'illégalité de
l'État, enfin des actions étatiques et
qui sont complètement illégales, je me
dis si je si je dois dénoncer des
actions illégales de l'État, moi il faut
que je sois clean. Si tu peux pas
critiquer quelqu'un si toi tu étais pas
clean. Donc du coup on se dit bah on va
on va attaquer l'État et montrer les
irgarités d'état. Et ce qui a fait chier
le système étatique, ce qui a fait chier
le ministère public, c'est pas le fait
qu'on héberge des noirs, c'est le fait
en fait qu'on leur dise bah ce que vous
faites c'est illégal. Et à partir de ce
moment-là, ça a été vraiment la guerre
de l'image, la guerre de de la prise de
parole donc des médias parce que pour
moi les médias c'est quand même un un
haut-parleur en fait. Ça devrait être un
contrepouvoir le média quoi. Et je crois
qu'on peut être d'accord là-dessus où on
donne la possibilité à des gens de
s'exprimer et de faire une action
politique de par leur parole, une une
parole qui soit citoyenne et et du coup
ben cette bataille juridique éclate. Le
préfet il pète un plomb parce qu'il se
sent accusé.
Comment il s'appelle ?
Il s'appelle Leclerc. Il est dans en
Sainte Saint-Denis maintenant.
Et euh et surtout moi je me dis comment
je fais alors donc du coup qui on a en
face en face on a l'État d'accord avec
qui qui gère une police qui leur donne
des des ordres qui sont complètement
irréguliers complètement illégaux et
nous qu'est-ce qu'on a comme arbre comme
arme ? Donc c'est soit la violence euh
mais tu fais bon à quoi bon on va perdre
de toute façon ou soit c'est joué dans
leur jeux. eux, ils m'ont attaqué avec
la médiatisation parce qu'ils ont de
suite communiqué sur le noborder et
cetera idéologue qui fait passer des
gens n
et surtout
trafiquant non ? Trafiquant,
ouais, trafiquant enfin total quoi. Et
et du coup, il y a il y a il y a ce côté
médiatique, il y a le côté aussi
juridique où ils m'ont eux poursuivi
juridiquement et cetera et je me suis
dit ce qu'il faut c'est se battre bah
pour de la com.
Alors je te coupe.
Vas-y.
Ils t'ont poursuivi juridiquement. Il te
demandait combien tu risquais combien ?
C'est c'est pour pour ramasser pour
ramasser des des gens chétifs sur le
bord de la route
les faire passer parce que tu supportes
pas bah qui dorment dans la montagne par
le froid, par l'humidité ou par quoi que
ce soit tu supportes pas. Donc c'est
combien pour ça ?
C'est 5 ferme et 30000 € d'amende.
C'est beaucoup.
Puis la prison, il y a pas de tireuse,
il y a rien.
Merde,
pas boire de bière, ça
ou il un peu de cheat.
Je pense je pense qu'il y a des moyen
d'acheter des bières en prison. Ça va
être compliqué.
Et euh
tu m'as coupé, je sais plus, je sais
plus où j'en étais là.
Le procureur, tu les as attaqué, tu as
répondu sur le terrain.
Ouais. Et euh et puis du coup euh le le
et surtout avec ce trucl-là donc du coup
nous on a le côté médiatique, on va
essayer de travailler le média donc la
com et on va on va attaquer sur le le
plan juridique donc on s'entoure
d'avocat de juristes et cetera
qui paye
et euh ça c'est Soro.
Non [rires]
c'est qui Soro ? Non, son je disais
c'est une blague. C'est une blague. Non,
c'est c'est des bah c'est des militants
qui bah après, on est on est vachement
économe, c'est on on construit tout
nous-même parce qu'on a quand même dû
faire des cuisines, on a dû faire de de
de d'organiser l'hébergement et cetera
et on est assez économe et surtout il y
a des avocats qui travaillent
bénévolement. Donc on est on est on est
très économe dans dans notre façon de
d'agir quoi. Et surtout je je pense
aussi qu'il y a il y a il y a ce qu'ils
ont fait avec moi, c'est la
personnification, tu vois. et et
grossière erreur.
Non non, c'est pas
bah les gens ont besoin de de figure en
fait. c'est pas moi qui le veut, c'est
la société qu'il veut quoi. Donc et j'ai
vu le la façon de communiquer, ça a été
Ouais, Cédric et Erou, regardez, lui
c'est un méchant et cetera. Et je me
suis dit, ben au lieu de critiquer la
police, de dire "Ouais, les policiers
sont des salots, des racistes et cetera,
je me suis dit moi je vais attaquer leur
chef et je lui donner un nom et une
image." Et donc je me suis dit le préfet
Leclerc et on chaque fois qu'on
communiquait, on mettait une photo de sa
gueule et on disait notre ennemi c'est
préfet lecler. La police non, on a pas
de problème avec la police mais c'est le
profet Lecler. Et après en politique, on
a choisi au lieu de prendre l'extrême
droite, la famille Le Pen et cetera,
cette dynastie, on s'est dit plutôt on
va prendre Sioti. Parce que Siotti, Eric
Sioti, c'est un mec à incarne une droite
extrême du racisme, la stigmatisation.
Pourquoi du racisme ?
Bah parce qu'il focalise. Il il focalise
et sur sa com, il est vachement
làdedans.
C'est pas c'est pas du racisme
de focaliser.
C'est quoi ? C'est du populisme. C'est
quoi ?
Ouais, c'est servir du racisme pour
faire du populisme, c'est pas
été condamné pour racisme ? Non,
non, non, non. Mais par contre, moi là,
je vais être condamné pour diffamation.
[rires]
Et alors, du coup, on se dit bon, lui,
il va incarner la politique de droite
extrême, le le préfet, il va incarner
euh le côté police et cetera et euh et
on et on on les attaque là-dessus. Et le
préfet lui
il supporte pas en fait parce qu'il
souvent il est là quand on communique on
dit oui le préfet a été condamné au
tribal administratif. Il dit non c'est
pas moi qui a été condamné en tant que
personne. Il dit c'est les actions de la
police qui ont été condamnées. Et lui
dit moi c'est c'est pas moi. Mais il a
mais il a un peu raison. Il a un peu
raison. Il a un peu raison parce que
c'est pas du pénal en fait c'est du
tribunal administratif. puis autistratif
enf tu tu attaques des procédures
administratives et tu attaques pas à la
personne.
Et et du coup lui le préfet il pète un
peu un plomb et ce qu'il fait c'est
qu'il autour de chez moi parce que
entre-temps c'est que les personnes on
va plus les chercher comme je disais
tout à l'heure c'est que les personnes
arrivent toutes seules et on développe
aussi
le le le la demande d'asile la prise en
charge des mineurs isolés on force Eric
Sioti qui était à l'époque président du
département des ales maritimes pour
venir chercher les mineurs isolés dans
la veille de la Roya
et
faire son job quoi.
Ouais faire son job. Il avait un peu les
boules mais il é un peu obligé parce que
voilà c'est un peu rappelé que c'était
toi moi et et les gens qui sont là qui
lui payons son salaire ou tu lui as
rappelé un petit peu ? Non mais il y a
pas besoin mais il sait quoi. Après
c'est pas un salaire, c'est un élu mais
et euh
voilà quoi je peux dire moi tu
as attaqué si ça les a fait chier.
Ouais ouais et du coup je disais ouais
je disais donc le préfet il pète un
plomb et il fait venir plein de gendes
d'armes mobiles autour de mon domicile.
Donc en fait les gens d'armes mobiles
c'est un peu l'équivalent de les CRS.
CRS, la police nationale et gendarmes
mobiles, c'est c'est des gens qui
viennent de de l'extérieur des
compagnies marseillaises, je sais pas,
lyonnaises, parisienne et qui viennent
dans la Roya et qui sont renouvelés
toutes les 3 semaines. Et ça ça a pour
but de pas de créer de lien avec avec
les habitants tandis que la la police
locale de proximité donc les gendarmes
locaux avec qui on a travaillé, avec qui
on avait des discussions ou avec qui on
a réussi à à amener de la légalité dans
dans dans nos actions de part la la
prise en charge des des mineurs isolés
et de la demande d'asile. Mais la
différence c'est que les gendarmes
mobiles, eux ils ont pas le temps de
comprendre en fait le temps où tu
arrives à discuter avec eux leur dire
"Mais est-ce que vous faites de faire la
pédagogie avec les les policiers Bah
oui, il bouge, les compagnies bougent et
tu as pas le temps de de faire tout ça.
Donc on se retrouve avec euh jour et
nuit hein avec cinq cinq postes de de
gendarme mobile autour de ma ferme. Et
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que sur
sur mon exploitation agricole, c'est que
c'est très très en pente et donc du coup
tu as la montagne, tu as la tu as une
voie SNCF qui arrive, tu as la route en
bas et c'est super dur à fermer. Donc il
met c postes de de gendarmerie mobile et
dont 50 gendarmes qui sont là jour et
nuit à vouloir fermer le le bah le ce
qu'on appelle le CCH, c'est le camping
Cédricou. C'est un camping international
de notoriété internationale
et mais il y arrive pas quoi. Il y
arrive pas c'est que les les gars les
gens arrivent à à la maison et arrivent
à accéder à leur droit arrive en fait on
a créé une espèce de de de
sous-préfecture des Altes maritimes.
Donc je suis devenu préfet, c'est un peu
la classe quand même. Et c'est une
blague. et on a réussi à monter en fait
une procédure légale et régulière contre
le système étatique et grâce aussi à la
gendarmerie local.
Donc il te surveille. Quelles sont les
méthodes invasives qu'ils ont utilisé ?
Alors la la le présentiel c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont fait le périmètre. Est-ce
qu'ils t'ont mis des caméras, des micros
? Ils écoutent tes conversations ?
Ils ont criblé tes tes ton entourage ?
Ils ont fait quelque chose ? Ils ont ils
ont échangé les antennes
de chez Orange à côté de chez toi pour
mettre les leurs. Ils ont fait quoi ?
On sait pas tout ce qu'ils ont fait.
Mais en tout cas ce qu'on sait euh c'est
que par exemple pour montrer
l'illégalité de l'État en fait c'est
qu'on allait au tribunal administratif,
c'est que ça interdit en fait pour
l'État de de mettre des contrôles
policiers systématiques autour de de de
chez des individus ou même sur la route.
C'est interdit pendant plus de 12
heures. Et on attaque on attaque cette
procédure au tribunal administratif.
Et donc on fait venir un un nuissier de
justice qui vient pendant une semaine le
matin et le soir pour constater qu'il y
a bien des gendarmes mobiles et un
contrôle de d'identité systématique des
personnes qui rentraient, qui sortaient
de chez moi et cetera.
Et euh et le préfet vient lui-même se
défendre au tribunal administratif et il
dit "C'est pas vrai et en fait c'est
dingue quand même. ment, il ment,
il ment, il ment face à la justice et
mais la justice le sait très bien parce
que tous les médias qui sont passés à la
maison, tous les journalistes qui sont
passés à la maison, tous les habitants
de la veille de la roya ont très bien vu
tous ces bus de CRS, enfin de gendarmes
mobile parqués autour de chez moi et il
ment et il dit non mais en fait Cédricou
fait venir le le Luissier que quand il y
avait des gendarmes mais entre-temps bah
il s'était parti. Donc le préfet qui est
qui est un employé de l'État hein, c'est
pas un mec qu'on a élu, tu vois, c'est
il y a rien de démocratique dans dans le
dans dans le poste de préfet en fait,
hein. C'est un mec un préfet c'est un
c'est un mec, c'est un salarié qui euh
qui lui suit des directives
ministérielles. Le ministère lui dit
"Bon, toi dans ce département-là, tu vas
lutter contre la prostitution. Toi
là-bas dans ce département là, tu vas
mettre le le l'axe principal sur euh les
militants d'extrême gauche. Toi là-bas,
tu vas je sais pas lutter contre par
exemple la migration. Et et le préfet
son rôle c'est de de de prendre en
compte des directives ministérielles et
euh et de les rendre légal et de de
s'appuyer sur des textes de loi et de
dire "Bon, OK, et lui en fait le préfet
il a rien fait de tout ça mais je pense
pas que ça soit lui de son propre sort
qui s'est dit tiens je vais lutter
contre l'immigration quitte à être dans
l'illégalité et je pense qu'il a parce
que là de venir enin Saint-en après la
gestion qu'il a faite ça a été ça a été
euh comment dire ? Il a été promu en
fait, tu vois. Sé à mon avis c'est
compliqué.
Ah non, c'est un gros département. Tu
rigoles ? C'est un gros département et
pour une carrière être préfet de Saint-
Saint-Denis, c'est pas rien quoi. C'est
c'est quand même c'est pas rien quoi.
Revenons quand tu dis il ment en disant
que c'est pas vrai, est-ce qu'il a été
repris ? Qu'est-ce que le juge lui a dit
? Bon,
le juge, il a il a consenti que qu'il y
avait du mensonge, mais il a dit que
c'était pas de son ressort et il a dit
c'est du ressort de du du Conseil
d'État, quoi. Et c'est pas de son
ressort parce qu'il y a il y a pas de il
y a pas d'urgence dans le voilà, en
fait, il s un peu il s'est un peu
défilé, il s'est un peu faufilé. Mais ce
qui est compliqué, c'est que comment tu
fais toi en tant que citoyen pour
attaquer au pénal ? parce qu' c'est au
pénal qu'il faudrait l'attaquer parce
que le le mec il a quand même il a été
condamné plus de 400 fois et il
a été condamné son administration ou
son administration donc c'est pas du
pénal c'est c'est voilà mais c'est pas
pareil c'est vrai que c'est pas pareil
mais oui c'est pas pareil mais du coup
ça aurait été du parquet donc de la
justice donc le parquet c'est c'est le
procureur de la République à ouvrir une
enquête pour mise en danger de mineur
isolés et cetera et ils font pas et nous
qu'est-ce qu'on a en tant que citoyen de
s'attaquer comme à un préfet on n pas de
moyen parce que le moyen en En fait,
c'est donné au au parquet et le parquet
c'est des c'est des c'est des
procureurs. Mais les procureurs, c'est
quoi en fait ? Le procureur, c'est
pareil qu'un préfet. En fait, le
procureur c'est un type, c'est pas la
justice le procureur. Il faut faut c'est
voilà, c'est il représente le ministère
et c'est lui qui va poursuivre telle et
telle personne, qui va mettre en garde à
vue, qui va demander à ce qu'il y a un
procès. Après, le procès, il est étudié
par des juges qui eux sont indépendants.
Mais pourquoi tu fais comme ça avec tes
mains là ? [rires]
L'indépendance de la justice en France.
Il faut y croire parce que si tu crois
plus, tu laisses tout et en fait tu
perds tout. Il faut y croire. Il faut
donner la possibilité au juges de
pouvoir s'exprimer et si donne pas ta
confiance bah tu perds tout en fait. Il
faut il faut et c'est c'est
tu vois du Pont Moritti ministre de la
justice, ça te rassure ou ça te rassure
pas ?
Bah ça a rassuré tout le monde au début
et ça rassure moins les personnes
maintenant. Et euh
je sais pas moi moi j'ai pas d'avis sur
Dipon Moretti. Après je sais qu'il aime
bien faire du théâtre. [rires]
Il aime bien la chasse aussi. la
[grognement] chasse
et revenons à nos moutons sur la
surveillance. Euh est-ce que tu as senti
avec les coups de fil que tu passais,
est-ce que tu as testé par exemple
tuappelles Robert, tu diras "Bon Robert
là on va aller chercher des potes, ils
sont sur le bord de la route juste pour
tester si tu étais pas écouté en live."
On a testé ouais
et alors ?
Moi, je pense qu'on est écouté. Ils
appellent ça dans la justice, ils
appellent ça des fiches blanches. Et les
fiches blanches, c'est des c'est des
dossiers qui sont montés par le par
l'État et où on fait des c'est du
renseignement intérieur mais qui peut
pas être utilisé pour pour la justice.
Une note blanche, c'est ça ?
Ouais, c'est une note blanche. Ouais. Et
tu peux pas utiliser ça pour la justice.
Ça c'est c'est pas ça peut pas faire
office de preuve mais par contre ça peut
faire office d'information. Donc ça veut
dire que s'il faut aussi me mettre sous
écoute avec des écoutes irrégulières qui
sont pas demandées par le parquet donc
par le par le par la justice. Si le
préfet fait ça, il peut il peut
influencer le le parquet de dire ouais
on l'a entendu. Il dit qu'il fait passer
des petits noirs et tout machin
mais il peut pas la justice peut pas
s'en servir. Mais par contre la justice
en a accès. Elle a accès à ça. Donc ça
ça influence quand même le le le
jugement mais ils peuvent pas ils
peuvent pas l'utiliser. On a retrouvé
aussi des caméras. On a retrouvé des
caméras. Ça vaut 350 balles une caméra
comme ça.
Tu les as revendu ?
Non.
Ah ! Tu aurais dû. C'est quoi ? Je l'ai
prêté à un pote pour faire un film et il
a fait un film avec ces camérasl. C'est
pas mal hein, c'est bien. Et en fait, on
leur piquait les caméras et euh et euh
je suis allé voir les les les gendarmes
de Breay. Je fais "Moi, j'ai des caméras
autour de chez moi." J'ai alerté l'ACNIL
parce que c'est interdit de mettre des
caméras dans l'espace public. caméra,
ils sont fait ou
et et c'était à personne. Je fais "Ah
ouais, c'est à personne. Bah du coup,
moi je vais toutes les chourer et je
vais dire aux médias, donc servi des
médias de dire "Regarez moi j'ai des
caméras et cetera et pour il a mis du
temps à réagir parce que ça vaut 350
balles 400 balles la caméra et c'est
avec des visions nocturnes, des
déclenchements automatiques. Il y a des
cartes SIM dans les caméras pour envoyer
les images directement sur des
téléphones portables. Donc on en a volé,
je sais pas une quinzaine quoi. Et ils
ont trouvé un truc pour les as pas volé,
tu les as trouvé ?
Je les ai trouvé, ouais, c'est vrai.
Et ils ont trouvé un truc, c'est qu'ils
ont ils ont demandé à la SNCF de porter
plainte contre X
et pour vol de caméra. Et en fait, moi
j'ai été convoqué par les gendarmes dire
"Ouais, vous avez dit dans la presse que
vous avez pris les caméras et cetera et
il y a la SNCF qui porte plainte et je
leur ai dit bah est-ce que les caméras
sur les les chemins et cetera sont la
SNF ?" Non. Non mais il parle pas de ça.
Il aux alentours des des voies de chemin
de fer. Je bah là c'est pas moi. Mais
quand même la SNCF a a suivi le le le
l'état pour dire oui c'est mes caméras.
Alors que
la SNCF suit toujours l'État.
Non mais ce qui est fou ce qui est fou
c'est que nous on a les preuves que
c'est pas la SNCF parce que vu que c'est
des caméras d'éclenchement automatique.
C'est des caméras de déclenchement
automatique. Donc en fait quand tu
prends les les images parce qu'il y a il
y a une carte SD dedans. Quand tu prends
les images, tu vois les gendarmes en
train d'accrocher la caméra et décrocher
ou relever. Tu les vois les gendarmes,
donc tu as leur gueule, tu as marqué les
gendarmeries et cetera et euh et mais
après qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qui nous qui
nous euh parce que ça dépasse la
question militant, tu vois, on dit
Cédricou militant promis militant
promigrant. Moi j'ai moi j'ai défendu
des valeurs dans une vallée.
Non, mais quand tu as des mythos en face
de toi qui utilisent une institution
pour porter plainte contre toi et que tu
as la tête des gars, le premier réflexe
que tu as, c'est tu mets ça sur YouTube,
tu dis maintenant la SNCF a changé
d'uniforme.
[grognement] Non.
Oui. Oui. Pourquoi ? Oui, pourquoi pas ?
Ouais.
Mais ça a été dit hein. Ça a été dit. Ça
a été ça a été fait quoi. Elle est pas
mal hein votre grapin là.
C'est Oui.
C'est de l'eau. C'est de l'eau. Etth
voilà ce que je disais. Enfin c'est
c'est nous on n'est pas militant
promigrant. c'est qu'à un moment quand
c'est quand c'est le bordel dans une
quand l'État met le bordel dans une
vallée ou dans un dans une cité ou dans
un village ou dans un quartier, je crois
que c'est le devoir du citoyen à se à se
comment dire à faire de la politique
quoi. Tu vois la politique citoyenne. On
[raclement de gorge] on reviendra sur
faire de la politique. On va revenir sur
les images. J'ai vu des séquences
de gendarmes qui emmenaient des migrants
dans les locaux de la SNCF
et ensuite qui les reconduisait au
train. Il y avait des des des mineurs
isolés. Ça c'est légal, c'est pas légal.
Non, ça c'est pas légal. C'est pas légal
parce que il y a une députée qui était
venue parce que les députés ont le droit
d'aller dans les zones.
Bien eu ces images là d'ailleurs.
H
tuas tu as bien fait ces images ?
On a fait ces images ouais.
et sur un film qui s'appelle Allerretour
sur un c'est s'appelle CRS collectif
roya solidaire [grognement] et et on a
fait ces images là et qui ont alerté le
défenseur des droits et le défenseur des
droits a demandé au ministère de
l'intérieur ce que c'était il a fait je
sais pas trop il y avait quand même des
directives marquées au au à la main si
présence de médias ne pas mettre les
mineurs dans le train et après les gens
vont dire mais pourquoi mettre des
mineurs dans le train et cetera en fait
parce que
on accompagné d'ailleurs hein
non on accompagné non c'est sûr et en
fait pourquoi c'est pour les cacher de
la police italienne, c'est que le
préfet, donc l'État, euh a fait de la
rétention de mineurs isolés. Donc c'est
la séquestration de force he quand
quelqu'un veut pas être enfermé, c'est
ça s'appelle la séquestration. Et il a
fait du passage de frontière entre la
France et l'Italie en voulant détourner
des contrôles policiers euh italiens.
Donc
refiler la patate chaude au aux Italiens
sans leur dire sans leur dire en les
cachant, sans passer par le protocole
habituel de réadmission en Italie.
Et ça c'est grave. En fait, il y a un
moment où
c'est c'est même pas être de dire "Oui,
c'est bien la migration, c'est pas bien
et cetera." Si un moment l'État commence
à à se mettre dans l'illégalité, à faire
de l'idéologie, non pas une gestion
politique,
tu te dis "Mais la démocratie, elle est
où ?" Quoi ? À quoi ça sert de se faire
chier, aller voter ? De quoi ? À quoi ça
sert de de de décrire des lois ? Alors
que le mec, il est fuck, moi le
ministère, il m'a dit de lutter contre
l'immigration. Moi je limite, je lutte
contre l'immigration à tout prix et
c'est grave quoi.
Est-ce que tu connais la théorie des
bayonnettes intelligentes ?
Non.
Ça te dit rien ?
En gros, si
si si tu donnes un ordre, je te résume
trivialement la chose, si tu donnes un
ordre complètement dingue ou qui ne
respecte pas la loi à un policier, il a
le droit de dire non.
Ah oui, c'est le droit de la réserve.
Ouais, bien sûr. Mais après, il faut
qu'il soit conscient de de ce qui est
légal ou illégal. c'est que même un
contrôle d'identité, c'est pas si simple
que ça un contrôle d'identité et le
problème c'est que la police souvent on
dit "Ouais, donner les moyens à la
police et cetera machin, mais les moyens
à la police c'est pas leur filer des des
flashballs et des des matraques. Les
donner des moyens à la police c'est
c'est les former. Les former à la
déontologie, c'est les former à leur
métier. Et c'est que là, on a une police
qui est absolument pas formée. Et c'est
pour ça que
qu'est-ce que tuentends par pas former ?
C'est qu'ils connaissent pas les textes
de loi.
C'est 8 mois. Attends, c'est 8 mois. Moi
moi j'ai moi j'ai fait
moi j'ai fait 2 ans pour avoir un CAP de
mécanique. Alors il faut 2 ans pour
avoir un CAP de mécanique. Il faut 8
mois pour être flic quoi.
Tu connais tu connais la note
rédibitoire au concours d'entrée à la
police nationale ?
Non.
5/ 20
5 sur 20.
Donc ensuite c'est
mais mais après faut enfin moi faut pas
rentrer dans ce truc de dire les flics
c'est des incultes, c'est des ignards,
c'est des les flics c'est ça, ils
auraient pu être plombier, électricien,
juristes ou je sais pas quoi mais
Ah ben non
mais oui. Non mais
moi j'ai vu honnêtement moi j'ai vu de
il y a je pense qu'il y a beaucoup de
cons chez les flics, beaucoup plus que
chez les boulangers ou les bouchés. Ça
c'est c'est un métier qui attire les
cons
c'est c'est à la louche, c'est gratuit.
Oui, mais c'est une réalité quoi. On
voit ce qui se passe en ce moment au
niveau de la gestion policière. Mais en
tout cas, moi j'ai vu des des gens super
intègres et et des gens qui ont envie de
de de travailler dans la légalité et qui
sont décontenancés quand ils comprennent
que leurs directives sont illégales et
irrégulières. Et il y a il y a plein de
gens bien dans la police, mais à force
de dire que les policiers sont des cons,
à force de de de stigmatiser les flics,
je veux dire les les les bons flics, ben
ils ont plus qu'à fermer leur gueule
quoi. Tu vois dans dans le c'est ça qui
est dangereux en fait dans la
stigmatisation, c'est qu'on laisse pas
d'autres choix en fait. C'est comme la
stigmatisation des Arabes, des noirs et
des juifs et et des roues quoi. Donc il
y a un moment où si quand tu
stigmatises, bah forcément tu tu auras
que ce rendu là. C'est comme la justice.
Tout à l'heure, je t'en parlais de la
confiance qu'on peut apporter dans la
justice sur l'indépendance de la justice
des juges. Si on commence à dire à la
justice c'est c'est des pourris et
cetera, qui c'est qui voudra faire ce
métier ? Et qu quel issu de secours on
donne aux juges qui sont intègres et qui
ont envie euh de de bah de de faire une
justice basée sur du droit, une une
justice indépendante et c'est c là où
faut faire attention en fait dans le
dans la stigmatisation. On rappelle que
le budget de la justice en France est
digne d'un pays du tier monde.
Euh, je vais je vais te poser une
question concernant tes détracteurs.
Qu'est-ce qu'est-ce que tes détracteurs
te disent mis à part que tu es un
passeur de clandestin, un délinquant,
que tu fumes de chit, que tu es un IPI
qui pue et je t'en passe des meilleurs ?
C'est vrai que je pue ça pas. Bah,
il faut bosser hein.
Qu'est-ce que je leur dis ?
Le problème, je crois que le le débat
politique en fait de de de l'idée
politique, il est il est il est il est
il est il est il est pas enfin il y a
pas de débat politique en fait, tu vois.
Il y a il faudrait je pense sur la
migration, c'est sortir du clivage
promigrant antimigrant qui qui est un
clivage débile, une espèce de lecture
binaire en fait dureté pour des contres.
Tu vois, un peu comme dans les émissions
d'Anouna avec le leur truc euh pour ou
contre, mais c'est beaucoup plus délicat
que ça.
Moi non plus, il m'a invité, j'ai
refusé, c'est le seul média que j'ai
refusé, c'est Anouna.
Mais il faut Ouais, je pense qu'il il
faut arriver à à se mettre ensemble
autour d'une table et pouvoir en
discuter.
Est-ce que Est-ce que tu comprends leur
perception ? Est-ce que tu te mets à
leur place ? Ils sont dans un pays qui
économiquement parlant est déjà moribon
depuis des années, qu'on est en train de
se taper une crise Covid qui est en
train de [__] à plat complètement
l'économie. Ils sont en train de se
rendre compte que la charité chrétienne,
égalité, fraternité, tout ça, tout ça,
c'est ça coûte de l'argent et que ça
marche que quand il y a de l'argent.
Donc, ils sont en train de dire "Ce
gars-là, il est dangereux, il est en
train de faire passer des gens, tu sais
pas si c'est des terroristes, tu sais
pas ce qu'ils veulent." Hein ? Donc ça
c'est ça c'est leur leur
comment comment dire ça ? C'est leur
leur récit.
Quand quand tu es tu es face à eux, tu
leur dis quoi ? Tu dis "Moi, j'en ai
rien à faire, je suis français, je vois
quelqu'un qui est dans la merde dans la
montagne, je lui tends la main comme les
marins font."
La solidarité de la montagne et la
solidarité des marins, c'est une vraie
vraie chose qui existe toujours. Quand
tu leur [grognement] dis ça, tu dis
"Moi, je suis français, je laisse pas
les gamins crever sur le bord de la
route." Quand je suis venu de voir,
j'écouté un slogan de de pub pour les
assurances qui disait "Vous garez pas
sur les trottoirs parce que les gamins
sur la route, c'est dangereux."
C'est c'était à mourir de rire. Donc
quand tes détracteurs te disent "Tu es
tu es un danger public parce que tu fais
passer un message que avec Facebook, ils
ont Facebook au Soudan, ils font passer
le message qu' a le petit Cédric qui lui
protège contre la police." Donc ça fait
un appel d'air. Quand quand ces ces
gens-là toos ça, tu leur dis quoi ?
Après, il y a plusieurs questions là ta
question.
Déjà, moi je pense que pour la gestion
migratoire, je pense pas que les gens
soient d'accord. Enfin moins saintesprit
pour noyer des gens en Méditerranée.
C'est le c'est le cas en ce moment hein.
C'est l'Europe organise combien de morts
combien de morts en tout euh de noyade
approximatif ?
Ah je sais pas mais beaucoup. Je j'ai
pas les chiffres en tête. Désolé.
30000 je
Ouais je pense. Ouais ouais c'est je
sais je sais pas j'ai pas les chiffres
mais beaucoup en fait. Il y a une
organisation il y a une moyenne
d'organisé en Méditerranée et c'est que
les gens qui sont contre la migration
sont pas forcément contre les migrants.
C'est des gens qui sont contre des
conséquences négatives du à la
migration. Mais pourquoi il y a des
conséquences négatives de la migration ?
Parce qu'il y a une mauvaise gestion de
la migration. Et c'est c'est les
conséquences négatives d'une mauvaise
gestion de la migration. Et c'est euh
moi je pense pas qu' il y a de il y a de
nationalité à à la violence. Je pense
pas qu'il y a de nationalité
euh à la haine ou euh c'est c'est c'est
d'ordre d'éducation en fait et de tu
vois là en ce moment la gestion
migratoire, il y a pas de gestion
migratoire, il y a de la gestion contre
contre les immigrés en fait. C'est même
pas
pourquoi il y a ça ?
Ben parce que c'est un outil c'est un
outil de déstabilisation de de de la
pensée. C'est que on détourne on
détourne le regard en disant attention
le l'ennemi c'est c'est c'est la
migration. Et et mais le truc c'est que
je veux juste finir ce raisonnement là
en fait sur la gestion de la migration
c'est que comment déjà pour commencer
que les les personnes en migration n'ont
pas besoin de moi pour passer une
frontière. Ils ont besoin de moi pour
avoir une tente, pour pouvoir un repas,
pour avoir tout ça ou la considération.
Mais tout le monde passe et qu'on voit
les chiffres du ministère et de l'État
sur les reconductions de France en
Italie, c'est des chiffres qui sont
vrais mais sauf que c'est pas le nombre
de personnes, c'est le nombre de de
refus d'entrée. Ce qu'on appelle le
refus d'entrée, c'est des personnes qui
ont essayé 5 à 10 fois 15 fois de passer
et du coup une personne ben fait 15
retours en Italie. Donc en fait, c'est
des chiffres qui sont complètement
faussés. Et moi, j'aimerais bien que que
le que l'État me dise le nombre de
personnes qui sont restées en Italie
parce qu'il y avait des contrôles
frontières. Moi, j'en connais, j'en
connais pas. Pourtant, je suis sur le
terrain, je connais personne qui est qui
est resté en Italie parce qu'il y avait
du contrôle aux frontières. C'est que la
la la frontière, elle elle arrive pas à
bloquer les gens. La la frontière, elle
blesse. La frontière, elle précarise, la
frontière, elle alimente des réseaux de
de prostitution, des réseaux de traites
humaines. Et c'est la frontière. Si des
réseaux de passeurs existent, c'est
parce qu'il y a des contrôles de flic et
c'est que les réseaux de passeurs sont
payés pour détourner des contrôles de
flic. Même même si on éradique le le les
les passeurs et ce qui est pas possible
parce que ça existera toujours, c'est
que les gens passeront quand même. Les
gens passeront quand même. Donc comment
tu veux gérer un flux migratoire qu'on
t'oblige les gens à se mettre dans la
clandestinité ? Parce que si tu fais du
contrôle aux frontières et en plus il
faut savoir que la demande d'asile est
possible à la frontière et mais elle est
elle elle est elle est pas elle est pas
mise en place en fait. Il y a pas de
possibilité de faire des demandes d'asil
à la frontière, c'est qu'on oblige les
gens à se mettre dans la dans la dans la
clandestinité
pour pouvoir arriver en France. Comment
se fait-il qu'à Paris des gens qui sont
passés par la frontière franco-italienne
et traversé tout le tout le territoire
français en étant en situation
irrégulière en fait sous prétexte de
dire oui, il faut qu'on contrôle les
frontières, qu'on sache qui rentre, qui
ouais pourquoi pas. Moi c'est un
discours que j'accepte, tu vois. Je je
dis ouais pourquoi pas. Mais la
conséquence là de la fermation frontière
de la gestion étatique, c'est que les
personnes se retrouvent en situation
irrégulière. C'est pour ça qu'il faut
sortir de l'idéologie et avoir une
notion pragmatique. Et euh et c'est un
peu comme le vent, la migration. Si tu
as beau être contre le vent, tu peux
mettre des oléennes où tu veux pour tu
lutteras pas contre contre le vent. Et à
un moment c'est qui c'est un fait, c'est
une réalité, c'est que des gens ont
traversé les déserts, ont traversé
dictature, la guerre ou la ou la ou la
précarité économique, on traverse la
Méditerranée et la Libye aussi hein et
euh et c'est pas notre frontière à deux
balles qui va qui va fermer personne. Il
faut voir ce que ça veut dire frontière.
C'est que c'est vrai que depuis Paris,
on imagine la frontière comme une route.
Ça peut être vrai hein. C'est une route
avec une barrière comme ça. On va
regarder qui rentre, qui rentre pas.
Mais autour de ces routes, il y a des
montagnes. Et il y a pas longtemps, j'ai
j'ai publié des photos. dire voilà la
frontière à quoi elle ressemble et tu
vois de la montagne quoi c'est et là des
chemins il y en a partout quoi et c'est
ultra facile de passer et si on veut
gérer la la migration il faut le droit
il est pas si mal écrit que ça il est
pas parfait mais il est pas si mal écrit
et même s'il est pas parfait je crois
que c'est une base de réflexion voté et
par des gens et travaillés par des gens
qui ont été élus démocratiquement qui
représentent le peuple français et il
faut se baser là-dessus pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir gérer le truc mais le
problème c'est que c'est géré de façon
idé idéologique, c'est contre les
migrants après tout. Donc du coup, on se
retrouve avec des personnes en situation
irrégulière de partout sur le territoire
français.
Alors, je te coupe. Est-ce que tu peux
te mettre l'espace d'un instant dans la
peau de l'État, de nos fonctionnaires,
de la peau de nos de nos dirigeants ?
[grognement] Je te décris le biotope,
leur biotope, notre biotope
réchauffement climatique.
Mais
ça, ils en ont rien à fout du
réchauffement climatique.
Ou ça ça c'est sûr que il brassent de
l'air chaud surtout en ce moment. Donc
réchauffement climatique, accélération
d'immigration dû au réchauffement
climatique, contexte économique basé sur
des ressources compliqué,
système financier qui tient sur deux
pattes et demi.
Là-dessus, on a la Turquie qui a un 100
un centre de rétention avec 2 millions
de personnes et qui du jour au lendemain
peut dire là, je vais en lâcher 150000,
200000 300000.
pour déstabiliser Macron parce que
Macron il a dit que Erdogan était pas
gentil.
Est-ce que tu peux imaginer le degré de
stress de voir 300000 personnes arriver
d'un coup en garde de canne, en garde ce
que tu veux
avec un état complètement démuni ? C'est
pas vrai qu'on est démuni en fait. C'est
euh
si on a 300000 qui arrivent, je peux
dire queon sera démuni hein.
[grognement]
Mais non, c'est rien 300000 sur 70
millions de personnes. Mais
non, mais d'un coup
même d'un coup, c'est g enfin pas de
Enfin, moi j'ai créé de l'événementiel,
je dire, on a géré des milliers de
personnes sur des petits espaces, c'est
pas pas trop le c'est juste il faut s'en
donner les moyens. Mais ce qu'il y a
c'est que non mais c'est pas vrai que
que la France va mal. En fait, c'est pas
vrai que le système économique va mal.
Je veux dire, il y a des mecs qui font
qui font des milliards. En fait, ce qui
vont mal, c'est les pauvres en fait. et
le et la et la la le le la misère en
fait est incarnée par les migrants en
fait. C'est pour ça qu'il y a une
volonté euh du système néolibéral de de
d'attaquer les migrants [musique] parce
que c'est un prétexte, c'est que les
mecs se gavent. Tu vois, pendant le
Covid, moi j'ai des potes qui ont des
bars qui ont des restos, ils sont pris
comme ça et euh et tout le monde s'en
fout quoi, tu vois là enfin
tout ce qui est culturel, tout ce qui
est tout ce qui emmène à l'échange, à la
discussion, à la la discussion, c'est ça
de la politique en fait, c'est de
réfléchir sur des sur des
problématiques, comment nous en tant que
citoyens on y réfléchit et c'est nous
qui influençons les les les politiques.
C'est par notre pouvoir de de de vote.
Non, c'est pas utopiste. Non, c'est pas
utopiste du tout. Parce que moi je pense
pas que les gens soient au déco
on vit dans une démocratie.
On est on vit dans une démocratie
représentative. Mais je pense qu'on n
pas on est
on n'est pas si mal l'ti que ça en
France. Mais vraiment c'est c'est
on a la chance on a une chance
énorme de de vivre en France. Et moi,
j'ai vu des gens qui et je je je m'en
rends compte beaucoup plus qu'avant
d'avoir lutté tout ça, c'est qu'on on a
on a la chance d'avoir quand même ça,
des ces infrastructures même qui soient
étatique, qui soient avec on a on a
quand même la chance de pouvoir vivre
dans un dans un Ouais. dans une
démocratie. Ouais. Même si elle est pas
parfaite, mais c'est pas parce qu'elle
est pas parfaite qu'on doit tout
balancer. Et il y a un moment où nous on
doit se battre pour que pour qu'elle
soit pour qu'elle soit défendue et pour
la faire grandir. Puis ça se vit, c'est
c'est tu vois la politique bah ça ça ça
évolue avec avec voilà l'évolution du
monde quoi. Et mais de dire que la
France est en crise et cetera, c'est
c'est pas vrai quoi. Je veux dire il y a
il y a des milliards, le PIB a pas
baissé quoi. Je veux dire les les
entreprises du CAC 40 se gavent là
pendant le Covid quoi. Ils se gavent en
fait tu vois. Et euh et j'ai
l'impression qu'il y a il y a notre
discours ou euh ou euh espèce de
bienpensance médiatique, politique qui
sont là, oh là là les migrants
maintenant on a le Covid heureusement
donc du coup on sait pas trop qui c'est
mais voilà et euh et euh on on se fait
baiser en fait, on se fait baiser sur
euh sur euh sur sur où on doit agir,
mais la gauche aussi se fait baiser, tu
vois. Et et l'extrême gauche se fait
baiser aussi. et sur dire en fait il
faut rentrer dans un espèce de de
machine organisée par le néolibéralisme.
Donc elle passe par l'éducation des
gamin à l'école, elle passe par les
films qui sont bah les films c'est quoi
? C'est c'est c'est basé sur des
subventions. De quel message on donne,
quel message on apporte et on est dans
une machine néolibérale. C'est pas c'est
pas une histoire de complétisme ou quoi
que ce soit. C'est que c'est qu'il y a
pas de grand big boss. C'est juste un
espèce de consensus où tout le monde se
retrouve là-dedans et il y a il y a pas
il y a pas de de lecture objective en
fait. c'est que on se fait baiser par le
néolibéralisme et c'est tout. C'est pas
les migrants, c'est pas c'est non, c'est
c'est qu'on se fait baiser quoi. C'est
nos richesses, elles son elles sont
prises. Il y a quand même 50 % des
richesses mondiales qui sont partagées
par 2 % de la population. Et ces mecs,
c'est même pas l'argent en fait. C'est
que l'argent c'est nous, toi, moi, nous
pour nous l'argent c'est quoi ? C'est
payer le loyer, c'est payer les
factures, c'est se payer des bières au
machin ou un resto ou euh bois. payer
son de bois ou et et ou enfin et nous
l'argent c'est ça mais l'argent c'est
pas ça. L'argent c'est pas ça pour eux.
L'argent c'est le pouvoir en fait et
c'est pesé dans la balance. Et si les
milliardaires, tu te dis mais pourquoi
les tout le monde se dit mais qu'est-ce
que tu en as à fout d'avoir des
milliards sur le compte en banque et
tout ? parce que c'est le pouvoir, c'est
là où tu es influ et c'est l'argent en
fait. C'est un outil à la base, c'est un
outil de troc. C'est un outil de troc où
on va échanger sur une base où tout le
monde entend, comprend. Voilà. Mais eux
c'est pas ça en fait.
Toi tu as étudié Ricardo ? [rires]
Non moi j'ai étudié rien du tout. Moi je
je vois je vois ce qui ce qui ce qui ce
qui Moi j'ai moi j'ai bac- 4 quoi. J'ai
pas j'ai pas étudié moi. Mais on se fait
baiser quoi. Et la gauche se fait baiser
parce qu'elle veut elle veut rentrer
dans un système qui ne lui ressemble pas
et elle fait elle défend pas des idées
la gauche. La gauche elle défend pas des
idées parce que défendre des idées tu
peux pas défendre des idées et et
défendre de l'électoralisme. C'est que
quand j'entends de des gens de gauche
dire "Oui, on referme les frontières et
tout parce qu'en fait le c'est la notion
de fermeture des frontières espèce de
mantra de de tu vois de de de de
solutions facile. Ah, on ferme les
frontières, on va lutter contre l'exil
fiscal, on va lutter contre
l'immigration, on va lutter contre
mais de ces conneries en fait et on
prend les gens pour des cons et à force
de les prendre pour des cons, on finit
par être cons et on arrête de réfléchir.
C'est qu'à un moment, c'est pas parce
que tu mets trois flics à une frontière
que tu vas lutter contre l'excale. C'est
pas parce que tu mets trois flics à une
frontière que tu vas tu peux en mettre
six he tu vois Macron il a dit bon on va
doubler les flics pour le contrôle de
frontière je vu. C'est vrai il a doublé
les flics. Alors au lieu qu'il soit 15 à
rien [__] au bord de la route bah ils
sont 30. Bah voilà, c'est super quoi.
Mais c'est conneries quoi. Et les mecs
sont pas formés à gérer tout ça quoi.
C'est que ça sert à rien de de se faire
chier à élire des gens qui construisent
un pouvoir législatif et cetera pour
mettre des des des mecs qui euh qui euh
ont fait 8 mois de de d'étude pour être
flic et à gérer des trucs qui
comprennent même pas quoi. C'est qu'à un
moment il faut avoir confiance dans nos
institutions. Il faut avoir confiance
aussi au au Français et aux gens qui
vivent en France pour pour bah pour
raisonner pour trouver des solutions
ensemble quoi. Et j'ai l'impression que
tout se précarise en fait dans le dans
dans la dans le débat politique, dans le
dans la réflexion politique et c'est que
la gauche au lieu de se dire b on va sur
le terrain avec le Covid c'est compliqué
parce que les cinémas sont fermés, parce
que les bibliothèques sont fermées,
parce qu'on peut pas se regrouper, on
peut pas discuter et cetera mais la
gauche devrait en fait défendre ça,
défendre des idées. Et la la gauche,
elle défend pas des idées, elles
défendent de l'électoralisme. Et en
fait, ils ont juste envie, c'est de
passer au pouvoir. Mais à quoi ça sert
de de de vouloir passer au pouvoir juste
pour passer au pouvoir et en oubliant
tout ce qu'on est ? Et moi, je préfère
perdre tous les jours dans une minorité
et pas être compris par la majorité,
mais de défendre des idées, mais de
défendre des des idées à tout prix,
quoi.
[soupir]
On va rentrer plus dans le terrain
en ce moment. Il y a l'impression d'y
être làin.
Ouais. Ouais. Mais ça c'est le terrain
des politiques là. On va parler on va
parler là où nécessité fait loi.
En ce moment, chez toi, il y a combien
de personnes ? pas beaucoup parce qu'on
est devenu Emaus Roya et euh on donc on
a un accueil limité parce que on veut
accueillir les gens dans de bonnes
conditions. Donc on a on a six personnes
h
les c'est toujours les mêmes
nationalités, c'est toujours les mêmes
classes d'âge.
Non, ça a changé parce que maintenant il
y a des français et en fait les les
étrangers se sont fait grand remplacer
par [rires]
par des Français. On fait de l'accueil
inconditionnel, on est devenu maus mais
c'est ce qu'on a toujours fait dans la
roya en fait tu vois. aidé tout le
monde, on l' toujours fait et et on a
mis le phard médiatique parce qu'on a
aidé des étrangers. Mais l'entraide, on
l' on a toujours fait ça quoi. Et c'est
pour ça qu'on n'est pas militant,
promigrant. C'est pas une lutte pour la
migration ou c'est juste accueillir des
gens dans la dignité et de manière
inconditionnelle et que tu sois français
à la maison. On a un roumain, on a un
français, on a un espagnol, tu vois,
c'est des c'est on a des hommes, des
femmes, des jeunes, des vieux. Et euh et
c'est là où ça marche. Et moi, j'ai j'ai
vu, c'est vrai que ça peut être un
discours de gauche de dire "Oui, la
mixité c'est génial et tout n na mais
moi je l'ai vécu ce trucl en fait." Et
et c'est vrai que que pour éviter le ce
qu'on appelle le communautarisme, même
dans un petit espace he où il y a 10 ou
15 personnes pour éviter le
communautarisme et si par exemple tu as
on va dire cinq Français deux Égyptiens
et un soudanis je sais pas quoi, les le
le le le public dominant masse va va
prendre le de dessus sur le truc. Et si
tu arrives à faire une mixité, c'est
qu'il y a une une cohésion en fait sur
le sur la communauté en elle-même et tu
as pas de tu as pas de séparatisme dans
le dans dans dans la communauté.
Du temps où tu avais beaucoup de
Tchadiens, de d'éritréens, de soudanais.
Euh est-ce que les services de
renseignement sont venus te voir pour
dire voilà est-ce que il y a tu as
repéré quelqu'un qui pourrait nous filer
des renseignements sur les passeurs ou
des choses comme ça ?
Non mais ils en ont rien à [__] Non,
jamais. En fait, le tout ce qui est
système étatique, j'ai plus de poid là.
Non, mais ça va aller. Et non, ils s'en
foutent. Non, mais c'est pour ça qu'ils
s'en foutent.
S'ils sont jamais venus pour faire de de
du recueil d'information.
Non, mais nous on en a fait du recueil
d'information. On a on a en fait, on a
pris tous les gars qui arrivaient à la
maison et on leur posait des questions.
Euh, comment ça s'organise à Vinimi ?
Qui, quoi, les voitures, comment ça
passe, comment parce que moi j'étais
confronté à ça. Je descends à Vimi et tu
vois des des passeurs qui sont là devant
les flics, hein. Ils sont là devant les
flics, ils font un peu leur marché, tu
vois. Comme les moutons en fait, tu
vois. Tu mets les moutons gris là, tu
mets les moutons blancs là, tu mets les
moutons là-bas, les hommes, les femmes,
les enfants et tu fais ton business.
Ça fait penser quand tu décris à ça, ça
fait ça décris ça, ça fait penser, tu
sais, à la traite des esclaves.
Ouais. Ben, c'est de Après, c'est pour
eux, c'est de l'organisation pragmatique
en fait.
Et euh et du coup, on a fait un un on a
posé des questions au gars qui passent à
la maison. Donc, on a eu
les voitures, les plaques
d'immatriculation, les numéros de
téléphone, qui quoi, comment, euh des
gens qui voilà des services.
Combien combien
combien il paye ?
Ouais.
Combien il paye ? ou un passage, ça
dépend de la saison. En fait, c'est
entre France Italie, ça va de 20 € par
les montagnes, tu vois, à 150 €. Bon,
c'est toujours moins cher que le taxi,
hein. Mais euh ouais, entre Ouais. entre
20 balles, on va dire et 150, 200, 300.
Là, en ce moment, c'est 250 € le le
passage. Et du coup, on fait ce truc
avec qui quoi ? comment t ta ta et et
j'attends ma future garde à vue parce
que j'ai fait 11 gardes à vue et en en
2017 tous les 15 jours je mon garde à
vue quoi. ça arrêtait pas et donc du
coup toujours pareil aide au
au transport et machin de personnes en
situation irrégulière et je fais moi
j'ai de l'info et je veux que ça soit
partagé au procureur avec une liste de
personnes et cetera machin qui font du
passage et qui avec des des mafias
organisées et ils en veulent pas et ils
s'en foutent en fait et ce qu'ils
veulent c'est pour ça qu'on est dans
l'idéologie on n'est pas dans une
gestion pragmatique politique quoi.
c'est qu'ils en ont rien à [__] En
fait, ils ont voulu écraser Hou et et ce
qui représente. Parce que moi je je
parle au nom de gens en fait, je parle
au nom de de d'association, de personnes
qui sont passées par la maison et et moi
je suis juste la la bouche de ceux qui
enfin j'essaie de le faire au mieux,
c'est pas parfait quoi, mais j'essaie de
le faire au mieux. Mais euh
mais euh je sais plus ce que je disais
moi, le l'information que tu voulais
transmettre.
Ah ouais. Et du coup, ils ont une
volonté d'écraser le le l'opposition
politique et ils se servent de de la
justice, ils se servent du parquet pour
pouvoir m'incriminer. Comment ça se fait
? En fait, j'ai fait quand même 11
gardes à vue, c perquisitions, quatre
procès et j'ai toujours été relaxé.
Ils t'ont jamais mis des kilos de cheat
chez toi pour dire que tu étais un
dealer de drogue ou des choses comme ça
? Bah, ils ont peut-être mis mais on a
tout fumé donc euh [rires] ils ont rien
retrouvé. Il faut pas fumer.
Je je pose la question euh est-ce que ta
prise de renseignement euh euh elle
venait
plus loin que l'Italie ? Est-ce que par
exemple ils t'ont décrit ce qui se
passait en Libye, quelle route il
prenait, combien ils étaient, quel type
de véhicule, quel type de torture, quel
type de tout ça ? Est-ce qu'ils t'ont
expliqué avec par exemple c'est toujours
le même nom qui revient ou des choses
comme ça ?
Après, j'ai mais ça a été un peu le le
la qualité entre guillemets de notre
accueil, c'est qu'on pose pas trop de
questions sur la Libye parce que c'est
compliqué la Libye.
Pourquoi c'est compliqué ? parce que
parce que c'est c'est grave ce qui se
passe en Libye, c'est il y a de la
torture, il y a l'esclavage, il y a du
viol et tu vois enfin je vais pas dire
100 % pour on va dire 95 % des femmes se
font violer en Libye. En fait, il y a
vraiment une gestion de la traite
humaine. Mais je me rappelle à l'époque
où Kaddafi a été accueilli en grande
pompe par Sarkozi, hein,
avec notre blé.
Avec notre blé, ouais. Et euh et euh et
la la
menace de de Kaddafi, ça a été de dire
bah si euh si on s'arrange pas trop, ben
moi je t'inomde je t'in quoi parce qu'en
fait la Libye allait très bien avant.
Bon c'était une dictature mais en tout
cas économiquement bah ça fonctionnait.
Il y a beaucoup de gens de d'Afrique qui
allaient travailler en Libye. Euh c'est
un peu le Monaco de de de l'Afrique
quoi. Et puis qui bossaient et qui se
rebarraient dans leur pays quoi. Et la
Libye a a a arrêté la migration mais que
dans un sens, dans le sens du retour. Et
il y a des gens, moi j'ai croisé des
gens qui m'ont dit "Moi, je voulais pas
aller en Europe, mais le seul moyen de
quitter de quitter la Libye, ça a été
les bateaux." Et il y a une organisation
que que l'Europe finance par des camps
en fait, il y avait des camps de de
l'Europe finance.
Ah bah oui, l'Europe a financé. En fait,
on a externalisé les frontières de
l'espace Schengen, on les a mis on les a
mis en Libye et c'est c'est la Libye est
financée pour gérer la migration à la
place des Européens. Et il y avait des
camps en fait de de d'esclavage en fait
et de de travaux et cetera machin qui
était mis en place en Libye. C'était
l'Italie l'Italie au nom de l'Europe qui
qui sont allés négocier toute la gestion
en fait de la migration. Ils ont dit par
contre nous on va vous financer mais par
contre vous nous signez un papier pour
respecter les droits de l'homme. Un peu
comme Nike fait quand ils vont
travailler avec des entreprise chinoise
pour dire vous signez là pour pas qu'il
y a des enfants qui travaillent cétait
avant ça.
Et euh et du coup du coup on on a on a
on a financé des bah des réseaux de de
passeur, des réseaux de traites
humaines, on les finance toujours. Et
après, c'est vrai qu'il y a une
organisation en Libye qui voilà qui
s'organise qui s'organise quoi avec la
prostitution des Nigérianes d'un coup tu
vois à Vimi des Nigérians arrivés tu
vois après c'est
des eritréens, tu as des familles, après
tu as des gamins, après tu as que des
hommes seuls. Donc il y a quand même une
logistique derrière qui qui est en
œuvre. Ça c'est c'est évident quoi.
C'est évident. En terme de route
migratoire, donc les gens qui venaient
chez toi, c'était
c'est que la Libye.
Que la Libye ?
Ouais. Chez nous, c'est pas la Turquie,
la Grèce, les Balons.
Non. Et ça arrive là maintenant.
Ça arrive là chez toi.
Ça arrive maintenant. Pas chez moi mais
à 26000.
Ça arrive. Il y a le seul qui bouge,
c'est normal,
c'est le métro.
Ah ok. [__]
Et on a le Ouais.
Donc pour revenir à l'acquisition de
renseignement, personne n'est venu te
voir pour savoir ce qui se passait chez
toi. S'il y avait pas de l'information à
prendre de Ils savent ce qui se passe.
Je pense qu'ils sont tout à fait au
courant de de de de ce qu' sont pas ils
sont pas non plus complètement débiles
quoi. Enfin, tu vois,
je pense qu'ils savent Ouais, ils savent
ça. Ils savent ce qui se passe.
Ils ont des satellites ? Ouais, même ils
ont des gens ils ont des gens qui euh
sur le terrain quoi. C'est pas compliqué
à à savoir comment ça marche hein. Il
suffit de mettre un flick black au
milieu du reste pour vous comprendre
comment ça marche. C'est pas non plus
non plus très compliqué.
Euh tu parlais en début d'interview que
on on t'avait donné un sa briquet qui
était grand remplaciste.
Ça sort d'où ça ? Ça sort la théorie du
grand remplacement de l'islamisation de
la France et cetera. Ça
ça veut dire quoi ? Bah pour certains
euh on est en train de grand remplacer
le peuple français. Euh enfin pour eux
c'est une une je sais pas trop, il
faudrait leur demander quoi. Il faudrait
que tu en invite un pour qu'il puisse
s'exprimer. B ça pour être
intéressantin. Ça pourrait être
intéressant à comprendre quoi. C'est
pour ça que même ces gens-là en fait moi
j'ai pas envie de de les dénigrer. C'est
un peu même comme même sans être
complétiste les gens qui votent à
l'extrême droite
dans mon village j'en connais. Tu vois,
il y a des gens avec qui je vais boire
des couilles et qui sont d'extrême
droite. Et c'est ça que c'est marrant
dans les villages, dans les vallées,
c'est qu'il y a de mélange. On sait qui
euh de quelle partie la politique quand
même euh fait partie de la vie du
village quoi. Mais mais on peut boire
des coups avec des gens d'extrême
droite. Et moi ça m'arri des gens
extrême droite qui me qui me qui
m'appellent qui me qui me disent "Ouais,
j'ai ce gamin un restaurateur qui me
disent ce gamin là, je lui donne à
manger à midi mais là la nuit va tomber,
je sais pas quoi en faire. Est-ce que tu
peux le récupérer ? Et et ces gens-là
vont te dire "Ouais, je suis pas
d'accord qu'il viennent là mais il est
là, on peut pas laisser crever de faim."
Et et il y a un moment ce qui ce qu'il
faut c'est c'est parler de la peur des
gens, tu vois. Et il y a un moment la
peur des gens, je je peux je peux la moi
j'ai eu peur aussi au début, tu sais. Tu
vois c'est ces groupes de mecs là comme
ça attendre, bah ça fait peur, c'est
normal quoi. Tu vois les attroupements,
ça fait peur. Et et ce qu'il y a, c'est
que comment qu'est-ce qu'on fait de
cette peur ? Est-ce que est-ce qu'on
l'utilise et on l'alimente comme
beaucoup de de de politiques le font ou
est-ce que tu rassures ? Mais est-ce que
la volonté en fait de de notre ce
système politique a envie de rassurer
les gens ? Tu vois, moi je suis paysan.
Je connais des des gens qui sont qui
sont bergers, qui élèvent des moutons.
Et c'est pas par la liberté que tu gères
un troupeau, hein. C'est par la peur
hein. C'est la peur du loup, c'est la
peur de Et tu gères un troupeau par la
peur. Et la peur, elle est quand même
c'est c'est un outil de manipulation qui
est énorme. On le voit avec le Covid. On
le voit avec le Covid. Bien sûr, il faut
faire attention. Bien sûr, c'est évident
qu'il faut faire attention, mais on le
voit enfin on le voit on le voit tous,
on a des méfiances de par le
gouvernement, la gestion
gouvernementale. Il faut s'imaginer que
là maintenant on nous propose un un
vaccin et les gens ont peur de se faire
vacciner. C'est et je crois que cet
indice là, il est il reflète la
confiance qu'on a en en notre État et
notre gouvernement, c'est que les gens
n'ont plus confiance. C'est quand même
grave qu'en France la population n'est
plus confiance en leur gouvernement.
C'est alors c'est comment remédier à ça
? Comment remédier à ça ? Mais j'en
reviens tout à l'heure à ce que je
disais sur le le discours de gauche et
sur comment gère la politique les gens
de gauche. C'est que au lieu de de faire
de l'électoralisme et de faire donc du
populisme parce que le l'électoralisme
c'est du populisme et enfin des mago au
moins et c'est c'est de c'est de c'est
de bah c'est d'écouter, c'est de c'est
de rassurer, c'est de comprendre, c'est
de c'est de voilà d'écouter la
population quoi. Mais les les la comment
le pouvoir le pouvoir politique est est
bien trop loin de la population quoi. Et
question d'internet.
[toux][raclement de gorge]
Le meilleur moyen de réduire
l'immigration illégale ne serait-il pas
d'empêcher toute ingence étrangère
étatique comme corporative ?
Ça veut dire quoi ?
J'ai pas bien compris la question non
plus. [soupir]
Ouais, je vois ce qu'il
[raclement de gorge] dit. C'est un peu
c'est un peu aidon les chez eux et
cetera mais c'est un une vraie force.
Arrêons de faire des guares à
l'extérieur de nos frontières ou des
choses comme ça.
Moi je pense qu'il faut arrêter de de
vendre des armes et cetera. Moi, je
crois que ça devrait être c'est pas
c'est pas gérable quoi. Mais on le voit
enfin il y a pas longtemps, il y a
Macron qui a qui a invité un mec quand
même président de de d'Égypte Sissi qui
qui quand même a assassiné qui a
assassiné 40 personnes quoi. Tu imagines
? Enfin moi on me trait on me traite de
de oui peut-être que chez Hou il y a des
terroristes et cetera. na etre côté, on
a notre président quoi, tu vois le mec
qui est censé nous représenter qui a et
de quoi ils ont négocié. On sait même
pas de quoi ils ont négocié. Ils ont
négocié de la Libye, ils ont négocié
forcément de la vente d'armes ou je sais
quoi. Et on travaille un mec, c'est un
meurtrier le type quoi. Et moi j'ai eu
des j'ai des preuve de ça qu'il est
meurtrier.
Ah bah oui. Ah oui oui. Ah oui oui. Il a
il a tué il a tué euh 40 personnes dans
les de mois derniers là. C'est euh c'est
amnistie. C'est les sources d'amnistie
internationale.
Non, le mec c'est voilà c'est on
travaille avec ces gens-là donc après
c'est sûr quoi. Mais sous le truc de
dire et dans les chez eux euh ça ira
mieux et cetera, c'est que la migration
en fait c'est un truc de riche hein.
C'est que c'est c'est pas c'est pas les
plus démunis he qui migrent. C'est pas
vrai quoi. Mais on le voit nous d'entre
une migration à nous, nous européens,
c'est qu'on va dans des pays, qui c'est
qui va faire du business en Côte
d'Ivoire, qui c'est qui va faire du
business en Inde ou en Chine ou c'est
pas moi. C'est c'est des mecs qui ont du
pognon, quoi. Et l'immigration a
toujours été
voilà faite par des gens des gens qui
ont du pognon quoi. Ça c'est évident
quoi. Après tu as toujours une minorité
qui est là parce que voilà, elle se
balance dans le flux et puis qu'elle
arrive à passer quoi. Sinon, en 2016,
tous les héritrins que j'ai eu et
soudanné, c'est des c'est des gens qui
voilà qui avaient les moyens quoi.
Question internet, quelle serait selon
lui les limites à aider des migrants et
sous quel critère les définir ? Là où
les limites à aider les migrants et sous
quel critèr les définir ? Mais la limite
c'est euh c'est le pouvoir législatif
qui le qui doit le donner mais qui le
donne en fait sur l'accès à la demande
d'asile. Euh il y a des euh
quand j'entends Darman de dire "Oui, on
va arrêter la demande d'asile, tu fais
mais tais-toi en fait, c'est pas de ton
ressort en fait. Fais ton taf, essaie de
le faire bien déjà, ça sera déjà pas
mal." Mais en fait des spécialistes, ça
s'appelle off praisse les faire en fait,
laisse les faire. Et euh et euh mais
après le problème c'est ça, c'est qu'on
a le cul entre deux chaises de dire
alors la question c'est ça, c'est est-ce
que on continue à à être dans l'espace
Schengen, tu dans la libation, est-ce
queon
à adhérer à la convention de Genève ?
C'est ça. Alors soit on sort de la
convention de Genève, soit euh ben
surtout aussi notre Constitution. Notre
constitution, elle est basée sur quoi ?
elle est basée sur les droits de
l'homme. Soit on dit fuck les droits de
l'homme, pourquoi pas dire à la limite
pourquoi pas quoi. Mais euh mais à moins
que ça soit clair, pas qu'on soit là
faire genre payer des droits de l'homme
et et à et à faire du mal aux gens. Mais
il y a un moment, je pense que s'il doit
y avoir une gestion pragmatique et c'est
pas de l'idéologie de dire ça, c'est
qu'il faut l'encadrer et et et la
migration peut pas aller bien si on
laisse dormir des gens dans la rue et
qu'on dégage les tentes pour dire : "L
migrants, ils sont là, on va les
dégager, ils seront plus là après." Mais
c'est des gens qui existent en fait.
C'est et le coup de com c'est ça en
fait.
[raclement de gorge]
et de maltraiter mais ils vont rester le
problème il est là avec la place de la
place de la républque 3 degr ce soir
c'est c'est voilà
3 degrés
mais à à quoi ça arrive est-ce que c'est
une gestion à proprement dite politique
non c'est même pas une question de pr
migrant ou antimigrant c'est même pas ça
c'est une gestion pragmatique du
pragmatisme et il faut être pragmatique
tu vois et tu
question d'internet que pensent-t-il de
la politique de Macron et de la crise
des gilets jaunes Cette crise a-t-elle
eu des effets ou non sur ces affaires
humanitaires relatives aux migrants
réfugiés ?
Mais gilet jeunes, moi je me suis
toujours dit pour moi je suis pas trop
manif, je je moi ça m'angoisse le monde
tout ça ça me et puis je pense que je
pourrais devenir violent en manif. Donc
c'est pour ça moi c'est un truc que j'ai
pas trop envie de d'aller. Je pense
ouais être capable de pouvoir me faire
déborder et finir des violents en manif
quoi pour ça que je je comprends aussi
les violences en manif. Je je dis pas
que c'est acceptable ou quoi, mais je
trouve que ça c'est c'est
un peu légitime, quoi. Mais les gilets
jaunes, c'est pas les gilets jaune en
fait, c'est la France. Et moi, à la
place des gilets jaunes, j'aurais posé
mon mon gilet jaune par terre et
j'aurais dit "Non, mais c'est pas les
gilets jaunes, c'est la France." Et ce
qui a été beau dans ce mouvement là,
c'est que c'est au départ du mouvement,
tu avais de de gens de tout horizon
quoi. Tu avais tu avais tout horizon et
qui sont retrouvés autour d'un
rond-point et qui ont trouvé quelque
chose de de de super quoi, de de pouvoir
discuter, de pouvoir échanger, de
pouvoir et ça a été un un mouvement euh
populaire. Ouais, c'est un moment
populaire qui qui était basé sur la sur
la discussion sur sur la compréhension
de l'autre parce que sur des
ronds-points, il y avait pas que des
militants d'extrême gauche, il y avait
gauche, droite, des gens qui étaient à
politique et et il y a eu il y a eu il y
a eu une envie en fait de de dire bah ça
nous appartient et c'est magnifique en
fait c'est magnifique ce qui s'est
passé. Après, bien sûr, il y a eu euh le
le débordement par la police, le le les
images les images qu'on a et la violence
qu'il a eu faite au au gilets jaunes,
c'est quand même c'est indigne. C'est
indigne de de de de ce que représente la
France, quoi, tu vois. C'est Et les gens
sont fait sont fait éclater quoi en
fait, tu vois. Et euh et euh après la
question c'était "Est-ce qu'il y a eu
une incidence
euh dans la veille de la Royale ?"
C'était ça au début de la question. Euh
ouais parce qu'il y a des gilets jaunes
dans la veille de la Roya quoi. Bien sûr
quoi. Parce que c'est un mouvement
populaire en fait. C'est pas les gilets
jaunes, c'est la France quoi qui s qui
s'est révolté, qui s'est rebellé quoi.
Puis si si elle a besoin de s'exprimer
comme ça, ben allez-y quoi. Et
maintenant quand j'entends de dire il
faut demander des autorisations ou
déclarer les manifestations, tu le droit
d'administrer, il faut déclarer. Mais tu
vas faire [__] quoi, j'ai envie de
leur dire. Mais mais de où de où tu vas
déclarer une manifestation ou euh mais
il y a ça a pas de sens parce que c'est
la base en fait, tu vois la la de sortir
dans la rue du même si tu as pas la
solution, même s'il y a un truc qui te
gêne, tu dis ça gène, j'ai pas la
solution. Mais mais ça sert à ça en fait
de se réunir parce que moi je dire moi
il y a quelque chose qui me gène dans la
gestion politique et j'ai envie de
discuter avec des gens pour mieux la
comprendre, pour mieux la définir, pour
mieux la la l'analyser, pour mieux la
construire et trouver des des des idées
ensemble pour pouvoir construire ça.
Mais ça ça serait le rôle de la gauche,
tu vois. Mais la gauche, elle le fait
pas quoi. La la gauche, elle le fait
pas. Elle est là, on a une gauche de
Nanti, on a une gauche bourgeoise. Et la
gauche bourgeoise, tu sais le où elle
est née ? Je pense que la gauche
bourgeoise, elle est née de de Cabu
quand il a fait le le bof. Tu vois la
caracature du bof où on a dit euh du
bof. Ouais.
On est du sud nous. Et euh et euh
c'est ça en fait, c'est stigmatiser les
les les milieux populaires. C'est de
dire bah regarde les prolos, c'est les
gros bofs, ils boivent des coups de nana
ou il va lire son journal, sa baguette
sous le pain, mais on t'emmerde les
bofs, ils t'emmerdent. Mais moi aussi je
suis un bof en fait, tu vois. Et la et
et la gauche, elle s'est complètement
désolidarisée du du peuple. Elle s'est
désolidaris qui c'est qui l'a reprise
ces gens-là ? C'est l'extrême droite et
la gauche a merdé quoi et a complètement
merdé. Elle s'est désolidarisé du peuple
quoi. Et là maintenant elle est en train
de faire d'électoralisme de faire du
populisme pour pouvoir retrouver le le
le Mais non mais elle se plante en fait
c'est que on a perdu des décennies
maintenant il faut les regagner. Bah, il
faut pas faire de l'électoralisme, il
faut faire du débat, il faut créer un un
discours intelligent de et et de et de
et sortir du clivage et de dire aux gens
même d'extrême droite de dire "Bah, tu
as peur, vas-y, on viens on discute de
ta peur."
Il faut discuter avec des gens d'extrême
droite.
Ouais. Oui, moi je suis pour moi je suis
pour discuter avec des gens d'extrême
droite et j'ai même pas envie de
discuter avec des gens d'extrême gauche
en fait. Moi j'ai envie de discuter,
mais parce que si on a le même avis, on
va dire quoi ? On va on va on va on va
sauter
quoi ? Enfin, ça sert à rien quoi. C'est
trop consensuel en fait. Moi, j'ai envie
d'excuter de discuter avec des gens qui
sont pas dans le respect aussi de
l'individu et cetera bien sûr. Mais oui,
moi j'ai envie de de parler de trouver
des solutions qui soient qui soient
positif pour tous en fait. Et l'idée
c'est ça mais la politique c'est ça en
fait c'est trouver tu représentes à un
moment une nation, tu représentes euh
des gens et à un moment comment tu fais
pour organiser les choses pour que tout
le monde s'y retrouve ? Je je saute du
coque àalan.
Vas-y. Moi, j'aime bien les coques et
les Annes.
Si c'est quand quand tu accueillis
beaucoup de migrants chez toi, est-ce
qu'il y avait des du racisme entre les
migrants ?
Ouais, mais le racisme c'est euh
c'était quel type de racisme ? Ça
s'exprimait comment ? Est-ce que les
gens des fois se retrouvaient violents
entre eux ? Est-ce qu'il y a eu des rix
comme il y a eu sur les bateaux qui
allaient chercher les les les réfugiés
en Méditerranée ou les
Non, ça va. Franchement, ça s'est bien
passé. Et même les flics me disaient
"Est-ce qu'il y a une volonté aussi de
l'état de qu'on se plante ?" Euh si on
se retrouve à 250 chez moi à un moment,
c'est super dur à gérer et c'est on
était pas préparé du tout à ça parce
qu'au départ c'était fait pour entre 7
et 14 personnes. Quelle taille fait ?
Elle fait de 2 hectares 5 mais ma maison
elle fait 30 m² quoi. Un peu petit. On a
fait des cuisines mais c'est la
cuisinière, c'est une cuisinière
domestique et quand on était 250, il y
avait il y avait des gares en fait des
en migration qui sont restés en place
pour pouvoir un peu gérer le camp et
ceterain. C'est pas moi qui faisait tout
hein. Moi je faisais pas grand-chose
même d'ailleurs. Et euh et donc ça a été
fait ensemble quoi. Il y a des gens qui
sont restés qui ont qui ont qui ont
préparé à bouffer et cetera et on a
jamais eu de de de problème majeur à la
maison. Ça s'est bien passé. Même les
flics me disaient "Putain mais
franchement la gestion que tu as fait
que tu as faite c'est ça s'est bien
passé. Don nous on s'attendait queit un
problème mais l'État attendait ça en
fait attendait qu'il y a un incendie
qu'il y ait un meurtre qui est parce que
c'est compliqué de vivre sur 2 hectares
et demi entouré de de de flics avec des
gens qui ont pas bouffé pendant 2 jours.
Certains qui ont mis 7 jours qui sont
perdus devant la montagne qui ont moins
7 jours à venir.
C'était le stalag. Non c'était unalag.
Stalag c'est quoi ?
C'est un camp. Tu sais un camp avec des
gens qui te surveillent. Bah voilà,
c'est un hasht alors
et euh et après non, ça s'est quand même
assez bien passé hein. Ça s'est assez
bien. Après, il y a forcément enfin moi
j'ai la faculté aussi d'avoir monté du
du des de l'événementiel du concert et
cetera. Donc je sais gérer une masse de
gens, tu vois 500 personnes, ben tu vas
boire là si tu vas faire caca là, tu vas
manger là, tu as de
type de pathologie les gens les gens ont
ramené chez toi
de pathologie
psychiatrique des plai quel type de de
de plai et la galle pas mal de gales et
donc là c'est la galère parce que du
coup c'est tout laver à chaque passage à
60° et cetera machin donc c'est
compliqué à gérer après les pathologies
ça dépend en 2016, c'est il y avait pas
trop de pathologie psychiatrique, on va
dire, et c'est venu plus après quand la
la l'Europe a travaillé avec la Libye et
empêcher les gens de partir où les gens
restaient trop longtemps en Libye et
donc du coup avec des des des
souffrances et qui arrivent ici un peu
déglingue quoi. Et euh
mais ouais c'est la déshumanisation. Il
faut faire attention avec la
Oh là làisation
et ouais ça crée des pathologies.
Tu veux du gib encore ?
Tu veux du gib ?
Non, c'était de l'eau en fait.
Quel quel est-ce qu'on t'a proposé de
l'aide par rapport aux gens qui avaient
des stress post-traumatiques dû au
passage ? Est-ce qu'il y a des gens qui
sont venus de dire voilà on fait une
cellule psychologique ? Est-ce que
on a été un peu abandonné par
toutes les grosses assauts ? Elles sont
un peu venues, tu vois, les Caritas,
médecin du monde, amnistie
et et elles sont venu en mode grand
Ouais. grosse assaut sauveuse là et
concrètement
parce que c'est quand même assez
institutionnel, c'est ce genre de truc
quoi. C'est une espèce de tu vois de
contrepouvoir préétabli. C'est un peu
comme j'ai rien contre les syndicats,
c'est important qu'ils y soi mais c'est
un peu comme les les syndicats dans les
manifes. C'est c'est bon à quelle heure
on peut faire Ah non pas aujourd'hui
demain on veut passer là. Ah non, pas
là. Ici, c'est c'est espèce de
contrepouvoir préétabli pour dire
"Ouais, on est en démocratie puis on y
va." Mais mais toutes ces assautsl
non parce qu'elles sont pas assez dans
l'opposition, elles sont pas assez elles
ont peur quoi en fait, tu vois. C'est un
c'est un c'est un contrepouvoir qui a
peur de de de perdre sa posture de
contrepouvoir et c'est ce qui fait peur
aussi même les politiques ont peu du mal
à se rapprocher de moi parce que parce
que moi j'ai j'ai pas de subvention
publique, j'ai pas de voilà, j'ai pas de
j'ai pas de mandat et ce que je fais, je
continue à le faire. Et
tu peux pas être contrôlé quoi.
Oui, on est contrôlé parce qu'on est on
est
tu peux pas être contrôlé en
Ah voilà contrôlé. Oui. Oui, parce qu'on
a un contrôle de par nos adhérents, de
par la vie associative qui est une vie
qui est démocratique, qui est mais
voilà, c'est pour ça qu'il faut faire
attention à la mise en place du
contrepouvoir. C'est c'est
institutionnel en fait. Donc du coup
quand l'institution des rails, le
contrepouvoir des rails. Est-ce
que est-ce que en recevant des des
soudainis, des eritréens, des tchadiens,
est-ce que tu as identifié des
combattants ou des pirates ou des gens
en fait qui passaient la frontière qui
avaient un profil bien particulier ?
Est-ce que tu les as remarqué à leurs
mains ? Est-ce que tu les as remarqué à
leur type de chaussures ? Leur type de
pantalon ? Leur type d'attitude ?
Jamais.
Non, j'ai pas eu Non, honnêtement non.
Les gens sont plutôt cools, hein. C'est
ça qui est assez fou quoi. C'est euh
tu vois, nous si on se fait contrôler
tout le temps, arrêter tout le temps,
fermer, il y a un moment où peut-être
qu'on peut vriller quoi. Et et eux sont
assez cool. Même les les les gendarmes
disaient "Ce qui est fou, c'est que
quand on voit des migrants là, fait hop,
les mecs ils arrivent là, ils se
comportent bien." Tu vois, les flics ont
pas peur en fait des migrants parce
qu'ils savent que les mecs, ils sont ils
sont plutôt cool quoi. Après, je veux
pas général, je dis pas le migristan est
un peuple de de de de super cool quoi.
Je dis pas ça, il y a des connards
partout, j'imagine. Et mais c'est pour
ça que ça, je reviens au contrôle aux
frontières sur ce côté de dire "Oui,
mais peut-être qu'il y a des
terroristes, peut-être qu'il y a des
gens violents." Bah oui, oui, c'est mais
c'est vrai, c'est une réalité quoi. Mais
c'est pour ça qu'il faut il faut la il
faut la gérer pragmatiquement et savoir
qui qui est là, qu'est-ce qu'il fait et
écouter les gens parce que les gens sont
pas écoutés du tout. Il y a un organisme
qui s'appelle l'OFI qui est géré par le
ministère de l'intérieur.
C'est dire quoi ? C'est l'office
française de l'immigration et
l'intégration. J'ai oublié un F, je sais
plus ce que ça veut dire mais et du coup
qui est soi-disant là pour faire
l'intégration et cetera machin. Mais ils
font c'est foireux quoi. Je dis c'est
c'est imparfait. Je dis pas qu'il faut
l'enlever, il faut l'améliorer. Il faut
le il faut le travailler.
Question internet. Est-ce qu'il a vu
entendu parler d'actions concrètes
effectuées dans son coin faite par des
antimigrants ? Oui,
il y en a eu une euh c'est des gens qui
euh qui ont monté une association
soutenue par des élus d'extrême droite
et qui s'appelait Défendre la Roya et
qui a demandé euh au tribunal en fait
qui qui nous a poursuivi pour faire
demander un une dissolution de notre
association
et ils ont perdu. Ils ont perdu donc ils
ont eu 5000 € de qui nous ont toujours
pas payé d'ailleurs et c'est c'est
marrant parce que c'est Bettati qui
était à l'initiative de ça et Bettati
c'est un élu de menton, un mec d'extrême
droite et qui maintenant est mise en
examen pour grand banditisme,
corruption, raquette et cetera et
cetera.
Présemption d'innocence.
Ouais ouais ouais. lui poursuivi mais
après et donc ils en fait partie ils ont
perdu 5000 balles qui nous ont toujours
pas remboursé d'ailleurs et ils ont fait
une collecte sur internet de dire oui
machin on lutte contre
l'immigrationniste Cédric Hero et son
association machin et ils ont fait une
cagnotte sur sur internet et ils ont eu
260 € moi j'ai failli mettre de l'argent
pour dire [__] parce que quand même
260 € sur une cagnotte c'est quand même
pas Ouais c'est pas très c'est pas très
voilà mais [grognement] ce gars-là il y
a un président de l'association qui lui
était garde du corps de la famille Le
Pen et c'est un mec, c'est un pêcheur de
Breille et euh et c'est un mec avec qui
on se disait bonjour avant et vu qu'il
avait sa position de président de
l'association de lutte contre Verou et
ses ses copains et il me disait plus
bonjour et je lui dis "Fernand on peut
se dire bonjour quand même on n pas des
sauvages quoi.
juste par politesse moi devant les
autres que enfin voilà tu vois et puis
enfin il disait bonjour et cetera et un
jour il est toujours en train de pêcher
au bord du lac de Breille quand il
existait encore avant qu'il y ait la
tempête toujours en train de pêcher et
je vais le voir je faire non moi j'y
connais rien la pêche et tout mais j'ai
un compagnon là qui aimerait bien
apprendre la pêche. Tu as envie de de de
lui apprendre ? Et là, il restait con.
Il fait
"Oui oui oui, bien sûr." Mais c'est pour
ça que tu vois dans le discours de de je
dis pas que j'ai raison que on tort
c'est pas ça en fait. C'est que même si
on est on peut être d'accord sur plein
de choses en fait tu vois et il y a ce
sujet là qui où on n'est pas d'accord
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'on qu'on
doit se mettre en frontal parce que si
on se met en frontal à quoi ça va servir
? Le débat il va emmener où en fait ? On
va on va on va on on va pas trouver de
solution en fait. Et c'est un moment il
faut donner de l'ouverture en fait à n
c'est même pas des ennemis en fait.
C'est pas des ennemis, c'est c'est euh
c'est des gens avec qui on n'est pas
d'accord et puis peut-être discuter.
Peut-être qu'on peut être d'accord en
fait au bout du compte quoi. En
discutant, en trouvant, en cherchant, en
après si on n'est pas d'accord au bout
du compte, bah tant pis mais en tout cas
on aura essayé quoi.
Il y a une question d'internet qui est
revenue plusieurs fois quand j'ai
préparé cette émission, c'est est-ce que
Soro se paye bien derrière ? Donc c'est
ça Soro, c'est ça ?
Ouais. [rires]
OK, je viens de comprendre. Est-ce que
Soro se paye bien derrière ? Comment tu
es financé ? Qui te finance ? Tes
comptes sont-ils transparents ? Vas-y,
je t'écoute.
On vend de la drogue et des armes et
non, je plésente.
Faut avoir des prix ou sur les armes ?
Non, on est financé par des euh Après,
on est on est on est on est assez
économe parce qu'on fait beaucoup de
d'autoonstruction.
Combien combien tu touches par Est-ce
que tu
Moi après alors je recommence depuis le
début donc moi j'ai monté une
association qui s'appelle DTC. Ça veut
pas dire dans ton cul mais ça veut dire
des fantac.
Ça c'est le problème quand tu montres
des des associations et que tu fermes
d'apéro avec les copains. Et donc du
coup après c'est dur a assumé une
association qui s'appelle DTC mais bon
bref et du coup on a eu l'idée en fait
les personnes sont restées à la maison
s'est dit [__] il faut trouver une
activité absolument parce que les mecs
devenaient fous en fait tu sais sans
rien [__] moi il les flics autour de
la maison [grognement] moi j'étais en
train de bosser dans mon coin les mecs
je t'aide je fais non non non tu m'aides
pas sinon c'est travail dissimulé et
cetera, la contrepartie et tout ce
bordel je non non non tu peux pas tu
peux pas travailler j'ai engueulé les
mecs pour pas qu'il bosse quoi. Et après
on s'est dit, on a cherché dans tous les
sens comment pouvoir leur donner une
activité tata, qu'il fassent quelque
chose leur journée quoi. Et du coup, on
a trouvé Emaus. Donc on est devenu
Emaus, on a proposé à Emaus, on dit
"Bon, on sait que vous faites pas
l'agriculture, que vous c'est plus la
frerie ou la récupération de machines à
laver, de meubles et cetera machin et
nous on veut faire l'agriculture. Est-ce
que vous serez chaud pour nous intégrer
dans votre votre fédération
d'association ?" Et euh et ils ont dit
oui. Et alors du coup ce que j'ai fait
c'est que je suis sorti du bureau. Avant
j'étais président de l'association, je
suis sorti du bureau et vu que j'avais
plus d'activité, j'ai donner mon
exploitation agricole à la structure que
j'ai que j'ai monté donc qui est devenue
qui est passé de DTC à Emaus Roya. Et vu
que bah je vis pas que de de d'amour et
de et de d'eau d'eau frais, je vis aussi
de bières fraîches et qu'il faut les
payer. Il me fallait de l'argent quoi.
Il me fallait et on avait pas assez de
tunes pour que je me salarie. Et euh
donc du coup, on a trouvé un
Où tu demandais ?
Alors au début, on a il y a une
tolérance fiscale, c'est pour les les
gérants, les les présidents de
l'association qui puissent toucher 800 €
par mois. Et Maus a dit "Non, il y a
trop de conflit d'intérêt. Nous, on veut
pas qu'il y ait de conflit d'intérêt et
cetera." Euh donc du coup, il dit
"Pourquoi vous voulez ?" "Parce que tu
veux garder la présidence, c'est pas ça,
c'est que nous, on n pas l'argent pour
que je me paye que je me paye un
salaire." Et et du coup, Emmaus a dit
"Bah nous, on t'aide pour faire la
différence." Et il me dit "Combien tu
veux que chez moi le SMIG ça me va bien
et du coup là je suis au SMIG et encore
1 an et Maus va compléter Maus France va
compléter la différence de salaire entre
les 800 et les 1000 200 balles de du du
SMIG mais sinon je je gagne je gagne le
SMIG mais après c'est sûr qu'à Paris ou
dans des grandes villes tu dis au SMIG
tu meurs de faim mais nous on se fait à
manger nous-mêm j'ai une maison j'ai pas
de crédit j'ai pas de voiture à crédit
j'ai j'ai une donc ça va quoi. Je suis
pas à plaindre, je Ça va très bien quoi.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi on dit est-ce que
Soros se paye bien derrière ?
Parce qu'il y a un truc de C'est vrai
que Soros, je sais pas trop, je connais
pas bien tout ça, mais c'est un mec qui
a c'est un milliardaire qui finance des
des associations qui qui aident les les
réfugiés ou les personnes en migration
et cetera.
L'argent de ton assaut, l'argent de ton
assaut, elle vient d'où ? C'est des gens
toi et
elle vient de don, elle vient de dons,
de particulier, de fondation. On essaie
de trouver des fondations qui sont
éthiques et euh
ça existe.
On aura c'est de la défiscalisation.
C'est évident. C'est évident. Les
fondations qui nous aident, qui
regardent pas trop ce qu'on fait avec
l'argent. Ça c'est évident. C'est
quelle fondation te donne ?
Je me rappelle plus. C'est pas moi qui
m'occupe de ça. Je je sais pas. C'est
pas que je faire de
C'est beaucoup d'argent. C'est comment ?
Alors l'argent nous on a après on a une
activité aussi, on a une activité
agricole. Moi mon mon avant la la ma
crise perso de 2016 2018 où j'ai fait de
l'accueil, j'ai perdu pas mal de fric au
niveau de la gestion de mon exploitation
agricole. Avant je faisais 30 35000 de
chiffres d'affaires par par an. Donc
chiffre d'affair c'est pas c'est pas du
bénéfice malheureusement.
Donc je suis tombé à 15000 pendant
pendant bah 2016 jusqu'à 2018. Et là on
a agrandi parce qu'il y a des compagnons
qui travaillent et cetera. Là, on est à
110000 € de de chiffre d'affaires, mais
c'est pas suffisant. Et de
fonctionnement, on a 1700 € de par an.
Donc là, le reste, c'est 60000 € qui
manque. Voilà. Mais en plus de ça, on a
acheté un un lieu à Brille sur Royaya
dans le village parce que ce qu'il faut
savoir, c'est que chez moi, c'est assez
excentré et les compagnons sont un peu
ghettoïsés, quoi. C'est un peu
l'extérieur, il y a pas de lien avec la
population et on s'est dit qu'est-ce
qu'il faut ? Bah, il faut trouver un
lien un lieu dans le dans dans le
village. Et on a trouvé un lieu dans le
village grâce à c'est un photographe qui
que connaît Michel Toeska. Michel Teska,
c'est le réalisateur qui a fait le film
libre et euh et ce photographe a dit
"Moi, j'ai envie de monter un truc
d'insertion par le billet de
l'agriculture. N na, je trouve quelqu je
cherche quelqu'un qui pourrait faire
ça." Et Michel Toescal dit "Putain,
c'est vrai qu' est en train de monter ce
projet là, va le voir." Et il est venu
me voir et il nous a filé 200000 balles.
Donc avec cet argent là et entre autres
avec d'autres gens, il y a des gens
aussi qui ont hérité qui nous ont filé
100000 balles et on a pu acheter un lieu
qu'on va rénover là en début d'année. Et
ce qu'il faut savoir, c'est que tout le
monde dit : "Putain, les gens super
cool". C'est super cool quand même de
filer 200000 balles dans une structure
mais en même temps, ça fait rêver quoi.
Il y a des gens qui ont 200000 balles et
qui vont s'acheter une super bagnole ou
un appartement je ne sais où et cetera.
Mais après,
c'est quoi une super bagnole ?
Je sais pas, moi j'ai un C15 donc bah un
truc avec des grosses roues et euh tu
vois
ou avec intérieur cuir, enfin une
bagnole quoi, une grosse bagnole. Il y a
des gens qui font ce plaisir en achetant
des bagnoles euh hybrides pour avoir
bonne conscience, hein. Donc un bon 44
hybride. Et il y en a d'autres qui se
disent "Moi, avec mon pognon, je me fais
plaisir aussi en en mon en en en montant
un projet, quoi." Et et ce mec-là, bah
il se fait plaisir parce que c'est un
projet qui marche, c'est un projet qui a
du sens et puis c'est sympa quoi de voir
des voilà de voir des gens que personne
ne veut et de monter une petite c'est
rien ce qu'on fait, tu vois. C'est rien
en fait. C'est 10 personnes, c'est que
dalle, tu vois. On a pas la solution
pour gérer les 170000 personnes qui
arrivent chaque année, tu vois. J'ai pas
la prétention de de de dire oui.
Combien les combien
combien de personnes qui arrivent chaque
année ?
170000 1400 je sais plus.
C'est un peu augmenté mais c'est dans
ces e là. [grognement]
Et euh
officiellement
du coup on trouve une petite solution.
Il y a des gens qui se font plaisir en
soutenant ça et puis euh puis c'est bien
puis ça a du sens quoi. Et puis c'est et
puis on a réussi à aussi à
parce que ça a été assez clivant dans la
veille de la Roya cette histoire. C'est
non pas que à cause de de des des
migrants, mais c'est surtout ma
médiatisation qui a énervé beaucoup de
gens qui étaient du cru et cetera. Ça
les a gonflé qu'on parle de la roya que
par Cédricou. Je comprends quoi. Et là,
on a on travaille sur bah avec le maire
actuel qui est pourtant un proche de
Sioti mais c'est un mec super ouvert,
beaucoup plus ouvert que les lut de
gauche qu'il y avait avant. Ça c'est ça
tu en de clivage droite gauche c'est que
ce mec en fait il a le le nouveau maire
qui s'appelle Alar qui est un jeune qui
a 26 ans je crois et qui a un proche de
Sioti qui était embauché dans le cabinet
de Sioti pour gérer la com ou je sais
pas trop quoi et euh il avait fait une
interview sur France 3 ou je sais plus
quel média et euh il avait fait une
interview qui était assez négative sur
ce qu'on faisait. Je suis allé le voir
je monsieur le mairefit il venait
d'arriver je serais bien qu'on discute
parce que vous que vous compreniez de ce
qu'on est en train de faire. On a jamais
discuté et on a discuté 2 heures sur moi
je voulais pas aborder ce qui s'était
passé avant, je voulais parler juste du
projet qu'il y avait après sur
l'agriculture, Emaus et cetera et c'est
lui qui est venu là-dedans. On a
discuté, on est on est d'accord sur
plein de sujets et on s'est compris, on
a pu travailler. C'est ça. C'est jamais
on va on n'est pas d'accord sur plein de
points, mais il y a un sur parce que lui
pour ses ses administrés, lui il faut
que ça se passe bien. Enfin, tu vois et
moi aussi il faut que ça se passe bien.
Donc du coup, s'il y a un problème, il
faut qu'on en discute et on peut pas
avoir des postures. Oui, moi je suis
contre, moi si je suis contre. et se
prendre la tête, c'est qu'à un moment il
y a des gens entre les deux, entre deux
mecs qui se prennent la tête, il faut
que les gens au milieu n'empatissent pas
et c'est comment tu fais pour que ça se
passe bien ? Et il y a des gens
intelligents à droite, il y a des gens
intelligents à gauche et euh voilà quoi.
Et on essae là maintenant avec ce
nouveau projet Maus Roya, avec cette
implantation dans dans le village de
Breille, bah que ça soit bénéfique pour
tout le monde quoi.
Si si on veut donner du pognon, il faut
envoyer le pognon où ? à Emaus Roya, il
y a des collectes. Euh et on commence
ses travaux là euh dans le 18 janvier et
on il nous manque un peu de tune. Il y a
une cagnotte en ligne. Question internet
qui est qui est un peu sarcastique.
Pourquoi génération identitaire peut se
procurer un hélicoptère et pas toi ?
Mais nous on s'en procure mais on le dit
pas. [rires]
Mais un hélico c'est pas cher vraiment.
Après ils font les marioles identitaires
mais
c'est 400 € de l'heure
? Non non c'est 22 peut-être. C'est 22 €
la minute. Donc je sais pas, c'est 22 €
x 60, je sais pas combien ça fait mais
c'est un coup de com. Après il ils sont
forts en com parce que tu vois
qu'est-ce que ça te fait quand tu vois
des gars avec des petits des petits
chaises du bleu bleu ? Moi
je les trouve trop mignon en plus
franchement les mecs sont tout beaux. On
dirait Ken et Barbie quoi. Et les meufs
elles sont toutes belles et tout. C'est
franchement en terme de com, ils sont
ils sont ils sont bons quoi, tu vois. En
terme de com, ils sont bons. Mais après,
en terme d'efficacité, tuis tu fais bon,
ça fait un peu pitié quoi quand même, tu
vois. Mettre des des filets.
Est-ce que tu comprends pourquoi ils
font ça ?
Euh ben ouais, c'est malin. Moi je pense
que c'est malin. C'est que tu vois
l'extrême droite, elle était elle était
antie-européenne et cetera et elle
anti-européenne. Marine Le Pen, elle
veut rester dans l'Europe. Non.
Oui. Maintenant, oui. Mais avant non.
Maintenant, elle s'est fait copine avec
Salvini et cetera et ils ont
européanisé, ce qui est un peu dangereux
quand même, le le l'extrême droite et
ils se servent de ces génération
militaires qui sont un outil de com pour
montrer regardez, c'est pas que des
vieux con qui sont en politique, il y a
des jeunes, des beaux gosses et tout et
euh
voilà. Mais après il font ça fait un peu
enfin moi je leur en veux pas parce que
tu peux avoir des erreurs de jeunesse
ces jeunes qui ont 22 ans et puis de
dire puis en plus dans du discours
européen de dire tiens on les renvoie
chez eux mais en Italie si c'est pas
chez en Italie de où tu remédies à
quelque problème que ce soit en fait tu
remédies rien en fait et et pourquoi la
France devrait
se mettre en opposition avec les
Italiens ? Les Italiens c'est gens très
bien. Pourquoi pourquoi l'Italie devrait
se retrouver avec la gestion de la
fermeture de frontière ? Trop facile en
fait. Tu vois comme à Calé. À Calé,
c'est le bordel depuis combien de temps
? Depuis 20 ans quoi. Calé ou je sais
pas combien de temps. Mais mais parce
que pourquoi enfin c'est débile en fait
tu vois, il y a une gestion qui est qui
est conne et et la France prend
l'oseille de de de des anglais pour
pouvoir gérer calé. Les Italiens
prennent l'oseille des Français pour
gérer Vintimi et autres. Si tu appelles
ça de la gestion politique, ils font un
peu pitié quoi quand même.
Est-ce que tu as entendu parler du camp
de l'esbos ?
Ah bah ouais.
Comment tu en as entendu parler ? comme
tout le j'ai pas été j'ai pas j'ai pas
trop le courage par des des potes qui
sont dans des milieux associatifs et par
les médias comme tout le monde.
Qu'est-ce qu'il t'ont fait remonter ?
Bah la déshumanisation quoi. Un peu
déshumanisation et surtout le la prise
en otage de de
bah de tous ces pays européens. C'est
ces mauvais élèves de l'Europe. Je sais
pas si tu te rappelles, je rebondis sur
un truc. Te rappelles les pigs ? Ce
qu'on appelait les pigs, c'était
Portugal, Irlande, Grèce, Espagne.
Ouais. Et tu vois, bah dans les pigs,
ces cochons en fait, c'est les mauvais
élèves économiques de de de bah de
l'Europe, ben c'est l'Italie, c'est le
Portugal, c'est l'Espagne, c'est la
Grèce et et c'est à eux en fait qu'on
qu'on fait payer la dette. C'est pay ta
dette quoi en fait. Et c'est à eux,
c'est eux qui se retrouvent un peu dans
dans la merde sur une gestion. C'est
carement la la migration, elle peut être
un problème quand elle est coincée en
fait, quand elle est quand elle est tu
vois, c'est c'est un peu le même
raisonnement que les banlieux, tu vois.
les milieux populaires, c'est qu'à un
moment tu mets tous les pauvres dans un
endroit, tous les tous les précaires
dans un endroit et forcément ça part en
bu, ça part en couille quoi. Si tu dilu
un peu ça, tu cr essayes de créer de la
mixité, mais tu as un équilibre qui se
fait et il y a besoin d'équilibre, il y
a besoin de de répartition, il y a
besoin de de de réflexion commune.
Question internet, pourquoi les comptes
de défencitoyenneté maus roya ne sont
pas publiés alors que visiblement vos
exercices dépassent d'après vos dir les
153000 € définis par les lois ? Bah je
sais pas, c'est pas moi qui gère la
compte histoire des publiers, je sais
pas peut-être. Mais ouais, il faut
demander, faut envoyer un message à emus
roya@gmail.com
et notre [raclement de gorge]
cher trésor hierère vous fera un plaisir
de vous répondre. Je sais pas moi.
Question internet. Comment gérer son
approche pragmatique au niveau national
?
son approche pragmatique au niveau
national.
Je sais pas trop quoi dire mais bon déjà
enfin moi j'ai pas la prétention de
d'avoir une des solutions niveau déjà
j'essaie de faire dans dans ma vallée
quoi. Je sais pas quoi répondre à cette
question là. J'ai son pragmatique au
niveau de quoi ? De la migration de
l'accueil peut-être.
Ouais de l'accueil. Ben normalement,
c'est fait un peu comme ça. C'est que tu
vois les
mineurs isolés, c'est géré par le
département et tout ce qui est accueil
de personnes en demande d'asile et
cetera, le 115, c'est géré par l'État.
Et c'est vrai que ce qui est pas normal,
c'est qu'il y a il y a il y a quand même
des grosses différences de gestion
étatique de par les départements. C'est
qu'il y a un préfet qui est un peu plus
humaniste, qui fait un peu ce qu'il
veut, l'autre à côté qui est un peu plus
antimmigrant et qui lui accepte
personne. Et du coup, il y a il y a une
incohérence au niveau national où il y a
des des départements qui sont plus
attractifs de par leur accueil que
d'autres. Et la la mairie de Paris, elle
en fait un peu ses déboirs quoi. C'est
qu'elle a voulu accueillir et cetera et
elle se retrouvait avec tous les les
gens qui étaient dans un département à
côté qui sont allés à Paris parce que
Paris a été mieux géré qu'ailleurs quoi.
Et malgré tout, malgré que ça soit le
Zbul, malgré que n'empêche, voilà, c'est
euh tu vois dans les Altes maritimes,
les migrants ils tracent quoi, ils
passent pas. Pourtant, c'est ça devrait
être géré par le par l'État et l'État,
on devrait demander au préfet qu'il y
ait une une gestion harmonieuse sur les
différents départements. Il y a pas de
gestion harmonieuse. C'est pour ça qu'il
y a un pouvoir au préfet qui est quand
même assez fou, c'est que les mecs se
permettent de faire de la politique
parce que en fait ils font un peu comme
ils veulent et c'est pas normal parce
qu'il il devrait y avoir une une
cohésion nationale sur sur cette gestion
là quoi. Et il y en a pas. Il y en a pas
assez quoi. Je pas dire il y en a pas
mais il y en a pas assez.
A-t-il vu Macron à la Roya lors de la
tempête ? Non, je vais m'occuper des
cochons [grognement] de Et en plus et on
n pas été
Mais Macron, franchement si on attend
après un politique pour se sortir de la
merde, ça se saurait quoi. Donc
après il a fait des promesses 100
millions d'euros d'après les élus de la
Veille de la Royale. On les a pas encore
vu les tunes parce que la veille de la
Royage, il faut reconster, c'est qu'on a
s pris une tempête dans la gueule et on
a perdu 50 km de route et 11 ponts. Pour
une vallée de 5000 habitants, ça fait
beaucoup. Et euh donc surtout au départ
pendant la tempête, on est resté sans
électricité pendant nous une semaine et
pas de réseau téléphonique pour certains
villages. Pas de d'accès du tout en
fait, pas du tout. Et
et seul qui ont géré vraiment c'est la
SNCF. Et la SNCF de suite le matin, il y
avait les bouteilles d'eau parce que
forcément plus d'eau potable et cetera
machin. Donc ils ont emmené les
bouteilles d'eau, ils ont mis en place
des drés pour faire passer les
marchandises et cetera. et ils ont
vraiment et de leur propre initiative
quoi. Et ils ont vraiment ils ont
vraiment assuré. Mais Macron euh ouais,
il a ben il a fait son show quoi. Il est
venu ça qui est fatiguant quoi, c'est
que les mecs mais toujours maintenant
quoi. Des fois tu as des réunions qui se
font à à Brille sur Roya ou tend t c'est
le village qui est tout au-dessus de la
veille de la Roya et à midi, on voit un
super hélicoptère
passer. On dit "Ah ça c'est les trois
préfets." Donc le préfet du département,
le préfet montagne et le préfet. Ils ont
ils ont mis un préfet en place pour
gérer la tempête et avec deux trois
politiques, ils vont se faire des
réunions qui sont absolument pas
ouvertes au public, tu vois. Et ils vont
se faire deux trois photos par les
médias. Oui, on allait attendre et tout
pour parler de la problématique. Mais si
tu montes de Nice en hélico jusqu'à il y
a 70 bornes jusqu'àattendre pour pour
discuter, reste à Nice et discute à
Nice. Si tu invites pas la population
dans la réflexion, reste chez toi quoi.
En fait, tu vois, tu as pas besoin de
venir. Il y a un problème démocratique
depuis toujours hein, dans les dans les
Alpes maritimes et sur la Côte d'Azur
sur
il y a pas de de de
démocratie en fait dans les Alp
maritimes. Il y a pas de concertation à
la population. Et je me rappelle il y a
un moment il y a eu c'est c'était en
pendant l'obligation en fait de créer
des communautés de commune des des des
agglomérations en fait. Et nous, on nous
a obligé de de de se rattacher à Menton,
donc à la CARF, la communauté
d'aggarmation de la rivière française.
Et nous dans la veille de la Roya, on
voulait faire une commune commune de la
Roya parce qu'on s'est dit déjà qu'on
nous maltraite, on est vraiment la
vallée des pauvres, on est vraiment la
la vallée maltraitée, délaissée, on a un
peu rien à [__] de nous quoi. On est
un peu les migrants du monde, tu vois,
les gens les gens
et euh et ils nous ont obligé, on a fait
une consultation populaire et donc on a
fait des des des bureaux de vote dans la
rue et chez des particuliers. Le préfet
de l'époque a interdit la consultation
populaire. C'est ouf hein quand même
hein. Et euh les gens sont venus quand
même. Il y avait les gendarmes pour bien
vérifier qu'on soit pas dans des locaux
publics, dans des mairies et cetera
machin. On a réussi à trouver les les
listes électorales avec le nom des gens
qui qui sont inscrits et les gens sont
venus voter. Il y a plus de 50 % de la
population qui est venu voter et il y a
eu 98 % des gens qui étaient favorables
à une communauté commune de la Roya. Et
ça ça a été invalidé. Et en fait, tu
vois, c'est c'est tu es en démocratie
représentative et tu as quand même les
les l'État, donc le préfet et les élus
qui qui se mettent contre la vie de la
population quoi. Il
faut bien garder son marché, non ?
Ouais. Ouais, ouais. Mais nous, on en a
marre quoi, tu vois. On en a marre et on
aimerait bien soit soit que ce soit
clair et qu'il nous laisse tranquille et
qu'on se démerde, ce qui est pas facile
he parce que faire des ponts bah c'est
compliqué mais soit qu'il le disent
quoi. Mais je sais pas mais
question internet. Que pensent-ils des
traducteurs de l'Ofién
la France auprès des réfugiés suivant un
séminaire d'intégration sur la France et
ses valeurs ? J'ai j'ai pas je peux pas
je peux pas dire parce que j'ai pas lu
les commentaires de l'offine mais c'est
les gens qui en ont marre aussi. Enfin,
c'est un boulot. Enfin, ils ont leur
donne pas les moyens non plus. Les gens,
ils travaillent là-dedans, il y a pas
que des salot non plus. À l'ofine, tu as
pas lu le truc là ? Je crois que c'est
une traductrice qui faisait des
commentaire genre euh
Ah non, non, j'ai pas vu. Je suis pas
Donc je peux pas.
Question internet, la balcanisation de
la société, ça lui parle, il en pense
quoi pour la France ?
La balcisation de la société, [rires]
bah c'est de la politique moderne. Vive
la France, vive la République.
Question internet. Faut-il donner des
moyens à chaque commune pour accueillir
des migrants ?
Ouais, ce serait intéressant.
Ce serait intéressant parce que surtout
ça ça crée du parce que c'est plutôt
bénéfique pour les les commerces de
proximité, c'est que les personnes ont
des allocations, s'appelle la DA, l'aide
au demandeur d'asile et ils ont 350 €
quand ils sont pas hébergés et 250 € par
là pour les personnes hébergées. et
c'est des gens qui consomment sur place
quoi, qui vont acheter leurs pain, leurs
trucs, leurs machin. Et et dans la V de
la Royelle, il y a quand même pas mal de
de d'accueil par des organismes, des
associations qui travaillent pour l'État
et qui qui font de l'accueil de
personnes en demande d'asile. Et les
villages sont plutôt contents parce que
au début non, tu la migration c'était
pas bien et cetera mais quand tu vois
qu'une famille bah sauve une école et
sauve grâce à au gamin bah il y a il y a
des classes qui restent ouvertes et
cetera, bah c'est plutôt bénéfique. Et
dans la ruralité, il y a il y a quand
même un manque de jeunesse et c'est
vieillissant, c'est une population
vieillissante et il y a quand même
besoin de de de gens, quoi. C'est pour
ça que ça elle est pertinente cette
réflexion et on on exclut vachement le
les maires ces élus qui sont quand même
c'est c'est le c'est le seul mandat qui
est le plus proche de la population,
c'est les maires en fait. Tu vois, les
députés sont loin, les maires ils sont
là, leurs administrés les voient tous
les jours. Enfin, tu vois, c'est Et il y
aurait besoin de de les euh comment les
considérer un peu plus sur une gestion
euh voilà plus euh plus nationalisée.
Ouais, je suis d'accord. On a un message
de la SNCF.
Merci pour la reconnaissance de la part
d'un chemine qui travaille dans les
ateliers qui construisent les drésines.
Et merci à toi. [rires]
On lui passe le coucou. Euh, question
internet. Quels arguments, s'ils étaient
démontrés, le feraient changer d'avis
sur sa conception de l'accueil des
migrants ?
Euh, je sais pas moi parce que si je
sais non, je veux pas qu'est-ce qui me
ferait changer d'avis sur l'accueil des
migrants ?
Bah rien en fait, c'est non il y a pas
en fait c'est c'est
non je crois que c'est la base en fait
l'accueil ça veut pas dire ouais venez
on est gentil juste gérer en fait et
pour pas que les gens ils dorment à la
rue quoi. Enfin tu vois comme porte la
chapelle les gens qui qui habitent à
côté qui se tapent
200 blacks en bas dormir dans des tentes
avec les déchets, les trucs. Tu crois
que c'est facile à vivre ? Et c'est ça
aussi c'est que souvent souvent c'est
pour ça que les réseaux militaires
associatifs ils sont là. les salots, les
les les racistes n na ils sont là. Mais
à un moment c'est une réalité, c'est
relou quoi de de vivre dans une rue qui
est qui est avec des gens qui dorment
dehors. C'est comme à Vintimi. À Ventimi
toutes les associaux locales disaient
"Ouais, les gens de Vintimi, c'est des
fascistes,
il râent pour les migrants. Tat tata".
Bah c'est évident que le soir quand tu
rentres, tuachètes un appart à crédit et
puis d'un coup tu te retrouves tous les
soirs avec des distributions de bouffe
où tu as 1000 mecs là devant ta porte et
à un moment c'est pas viable. Mais ça
c'est le c'est c'est le le gouvernement
qui se sert de ça. Créer le trouble
République pour faire part aux gens
quoi. Et c'est le gouvernement qui crée
le trouble République c'est qu'au moins
il faut pas déconner. Je dire à Paris
combien de de de baraques vide a combien
de logements vide il y a. Donc il y a un
moment si s'il y a une volonté étatique
et de de du gouvernement de que ça soit
le bordel c'est que c'est une volonté.
C'est pas une négligence hein. C'est pas
on a mal fait. Non non, c'est il y a un
moment il faut comprendre les gens qui
vivent en face de tout ça que c'est
relou quoi, tu vois. Je veux dire et
c'est pas qu'une question de migration.
Si tu as euh 200 mecs SDF français
machin qui squat en bas de chez toi, à
un moment tu as les boules quoi. Ou ou
ou 25 jeunes qui qui squatent en bas de
chez toi tous les soirs qui boivent des
bières. C'est pas parce que tu es contre
la jeunesse, c'est juste contre tu as
pas envie le soir quand tu rentres du
boulot à avoir du bruit jusqu'à 2h du
matin à pas pouvoir dormir et et voilà
quoi. C'est Mais l'État ça sert à ça en
fait. Ça sert à ça l'État, ça sert à
gérer ce qui se passe en dehors de chez
les gens en fait et dans l'espace
public. Et euh il faut pas se mettre les
uns contre les autres en fait. Il faut
pas se mettre les promigrants, les
antimmigrants, on n'est pas d'accord et
cement. C'est ceux qui font de la merde,
c'est le gouvernement quoi. Et c'est
tout quoi.
Quand tu avais 250 personnes chez toi,
est-ce que il y avait une organisation
spéciale pour respecter la religion de
tout le monde ? Est-ce qu'il y avait des
intégristes qui réclamaient de passer
les mains des femmes ? Est-ce qu'il y
avait des gens qui refusaient de prendre
leur leur leur menu avec le les femmes,
leur repas avec leurs femmes ou avec
d'autres femmes ? Est-ce que il y a eu
des des tentatives de viol ou des choses
comme ça chez toi ?
Bah honnêtement, il y a jamais eu de On
a jamais eu de Mais c'est très marrant,
c'est ça qui est fou quoi, c'est dans
cette lecture de dire "Ouais, les ces
migrants qui sont là musulmans à fond",
bah honnêtement non quoi. J'ai des gens
qui font la prière quand ils la font au
milieu, je bon ça te regarde, tu l'as
fait dans ta caravane, dans ta tente et
tout. Euh moi je suis que ça soit câau
ou euh ou musulman, je respecte, tu
vois, mais j'ai pas envie d'avoir ça
devant moi là comme ça ça me Et euh non
bah tu sais chez chez moi, c'est ça a
été géré beaucoup par des femmes he et
c'est une c'est une lutte cette question
là en fait c'est une lutte vachement
féminine en fait. C'est il y a
énormément de femmes de jeunes qui qui
qui œuvrent et et à la maison c'est
souvent dit "Ouais, peut-être que tu as
eu un terroriste. Chez nous, on a des
cochons, tu vois, on des femmes qui
gèrent, sexisme est interdit." Et
pourtant, on a des règles, tu vois.
Nous, on a des règles, c'est que si tu
bfou les règles, on te vire. Et donc
c'est sexisme, racisme, intolérance, euh
bagarre, ça paraît basique quoi. Mais en
tout cas, il y a des règles et euh et
euh non, ça s'est souvent ça s'est
plutôt bien passé. Ouais.
Question Internet. Est-ce que pour lui,
il y a une limite numéraire à
l'immigration ? 1 million, 100 millions,
100 millions ? Y a-t-il réfléchi ?
Ben moi, est-ce que souvent on pense que
toute l'Afrique veut venir ici ? Moi, je
suis pas bien sûr, mais honnêement euh
autant sur les les frontières internes à
Schengen, donc interne à Shangunen,
c'est ce qu'il y a intérieur de Shangun
sur la libation. Donc là, moi je suis
tout à fait pour la libre circulation et
où j'ai pas d'avis où c'est des avis
tranchés où je suis pas assez, c'est
pour ça qu'il faudrait amener à la
discussion, c'est sur les frontières
externes en fait pour savoir est-ce que
justement est-ce qu'on laisse faire la
migration, est-ce que est-ce qu'il y a
une régulation après ? Et ça, j'ai pas
de question et j'aimerais bien, j'ai pas
de réponse, pardon. J'aimerais bien
pouvoir l'étudier avec des gens qui
savent un peu plus que moi. Et
[grognement] mais en tout cas ce que ce
que j'ai vu c'est j'ai vu des gens qui
étaient en France et qui voulaient
retourner dans leur pays qui pouvaient
pas retourner et c'est que c'est une
réalité, c'est que maintenant si tous
les gens qui arrivent ici leurs papiers
se les font voler ou dépouillés même par
la police française ou ou italienne ou
en Libye et c'est des gens qui peuvent
pas rentrer dans leur dans dans leur
pays d'origine. Et moi j'ai connu un
nigérien qui voulait rentrer chez lui et
il pouvait pas. Il y a des protocoles
avec l'offille et cetera. problème,
c'est compliqué comme décision parce que
du coup c'est euh c'est euh un aller
sans retour quoi. C'est que ça veut dire
si tu rentres, tu peux pas revenir. Donc
est-ce que
revenir parce que tu as la honte du
village qui a cotisé pour dire non, il y
a des gens qui veulent qui veulent qui
veulent retourner chez eux, c'est pas la
majorité, loin de là, c'est une minorité
hein, mais et qui qui ne peuvent pas
quand même quoi. Donc est-ce que je sais
pas, il faut en débattre quoi. Est-ce
que si on laisse les gens circuler,
est-ce que il y a pas une régulation qui
se ferait peut-être un bordel pendant 2
3 ans et une régulation après ? Je sais
pas, j'ai pas j'ai pas
Est-ce que Est-ce que la police a fait
des faux documents pour pouvoir
reconduire à la frontière des migrants ?
Ouais, il continu à le faire. Donc déjà,
ils ont ils ont des des procédures qui
sont qui qui sont pas conformes, qui
sont irrégulières, qui ont été condamnés
par le Conseil de l'État, mais il
continue quand même. Et oui, il y a eu
des il y a eu des faux usages de faux.
Ouais. des faux papiers qui ont été
faits, des faux écrits par la police et
c'est super grave. Mais ce qui est
dingue, c'est que le parquet fou en
écriture, c'est les cours d'assise. Il y
a des preuves de ça ? Ah oui oui, on a
des preuves pour ça. Ouais bien sûr.
On va prendre quelques questions
internet et puis on on va terminer.
Ouais parce qu'il se fait tard et soif
là.
Euh est-ce que tu roules à l'huile de
friture avec ton C15 ? [rires]
Nous on fait de l'huile d'olive. Donc
huile de friture on sait pas ce que ça
veut dire. Non je roule au gasoile quoi.
Parce que je soutiens total.
Monsieurou, n'êtes-vous pas la
représentation de tout ce que déteste le
néolibéralisme ? Ouais, je pense. Ouais.
Et je suis fier de de que ça si je peux
les emmerder encore un peu plus, je le
ferai.
Tu as vraiment pas une tête de Ken, toi
hein.
Tu as pas une tête de Ken
de Ken ?
Ouais. Ken Barbie. Attends, ça va. Je
suis pas si horrible que ça. Merde.
À la place du gouvernement, que
ferait-il pour améliorer la situation ?
Je pense que tu as déjà un peu répondu.
Non.
Les délits et crimes sont-ils liés
uniquement à la pauvreté ? Bah non, on
le voit bien avec nos euh [rires]
Darmanin et Coco là.
Et Darmanin quoi ? Il est pas condamné
encore ?
Non, il est pas condamné du tout. Pas du
tout.
Non, tu m'aurais dit cusac peut-être.
Ouais, Cusac. Ouais. Non mais mais les
délit mais c'est pour ça qu'on on se
focalise tout le temps sur les sur les
délis mineurs, sur la délinquence un peu
violente quoi. Mais la la délinquence en
col blanc, elle est pas violente
directement mais indirectement. Elle a
une violence extrême en fait parce que
c'est elle qui est responsable de la
précarité quoi.
Question internet qu'on a déjà abordé.
Que que faire face au chantage de
Erdogan de entre guillemets lâcher des
ordes de migrants sur l'Europe ?
B qu'il est lâche et puis on verra bien.
Est-ce que tu as des livres et des
conseils pour les jeunes générations ?
Il nous faut trois livres.
Trois livres
et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations.
Bon, je vais commencer par mon bouquin.
Je fais un peu de com ça
et et j'en profite aussi pour qu'on
fasse un peu de com aussi. Oubliez pas
de vous abonner à nos réseaux sociaux, à
la chaîne YouTube en appuyant sur la
petite cloche, s'abonner pour avoir nos
notifications. Oubliez pas sinon il y
aura pas de de notification pour les
directs. Je t'en prie. Désolé de t'avoir
coupé.
Moi j'ai créé un bouquin qui s'appelle
Change ton monde. C'est loin édition
hein. Les liens qui libèrent
et voilà. Après il y a quoi ? Je sais
pas. Moi je dis pas beaucoup moi en fait
mais je sais rien moi comme livre je
sais pas tu as qu'aller dans ta dans ta
librairie à côté de chez toi et tu
verras bien ce qu'il y a à lire
si les librairies tiennent le choc avec
le Covid ou
un conseil pour les jeunes génération
bah ouais [__] c'est là vous faites
baiser quoi en fait on
il y a beaucoup de jeunes là qui nous
écoutent tu crois
ou il y en a plein
bah on on les on les baise quoi. Enfin
franchement c'est c'est euh
on a on a des vieux qui sont au
gouvernement qui ont [__] leur planète,
qui ont [__] leur travail. Euh on
prétend une crise financière et cetera
machin, mais en fait c'est juste que il
y a pas de volonté de partage. Et moi,
j'ai vu beaucoup de jeunes qui sont
passés à la maison et j'ai ultra
confiance en eux mais vraiment c'est et
j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus malins que ce que j'étais moi à
leur âge et et qu'on leur donne pas
assez le le cette confiance là. Je vois
beaucoup de jeunes en fait qui sont un
peu perdus dans leur dans c'est vrai
qu'ils font des études, ils savent pas
sir du boulot, il y a ce [__] de Covid
où ils sont obligés de faire des fêtes
clandestines pour se voir entre eux et
et
ce qui c'est pas normal d'ailleurs.
Mesure barrière, faut faire gaffe hein.
Ouais mais bon après la liberté des fois
t'emmène à prendre des risques hein.
Mais
mais faire prendre de de des risques a
des gens qu'on pas choisi, c'est
tu sais qu'il y a des gens qui sont
morts pour notre liberté quoi et ils
sont morts jeunes. Donc après il faut il
faut avoir une gestion qui soit
intelligente quoi sur le Covid c'est un
truc qui existe, tu vois, c'est une
maladie qui existe et il y a des gens
qui qui en meurent et c'est juste faire
attention mais pas arrêter de vivre tu
vois. fermer les cinémas, fermer tout ce
qu'on appelle ça ces commerces non
essentiels alors qu'ils sont ultra
essentiels sur bah sur voilà sur le le
l'éducation quoi. et juste faire
confiance confiance aux gens quoi parce
qu'on peut leur faire confiance et je
pense que c'est c'est tout et les
obliger à rester chez eux par obligation
en fait et enlever leur juste leur leur
leur possibilité de de de d'agir en
connaissance de cause bah c'est c'est
infantiliser les gens et et je trouve
que c'est négatif après c'est un are
sujet l'histoire de la gestion du Covid
et on
quelle est la plus belle quelle est la
plus belle situation que tu as été amené
à gérer avec la police là où ils t'ont
filé un coup de main ils ont
Bah tu [grognement] sais que je me suis
fait plus souvent euh contre contrôlé
par des flics et laisser passer avec des
gamins dans le dans le coffre que
arrêter mis en garde à et mais vraiment
parce que les flics savent en fait
savent très bien que c'est de la merde
leurs ordres que ça marche pas que ça
sert à rien et on est d'accord avec eux
en fait on discute on est d'accord quoi.
Etth ouais c'est ce côté de après il
faut leur donner confiance parce que si
tu les traites de salot et cetera, bah
du coup ils vont se fermer et tu tu as
aucune ouverture. Si tu leur donnes une
ouverture et tu essayes de comprendre un
peu leur position parce que c'est pas
que des les flics et les mecs sont pas
certains peut-être quoi mais la majorité
c'est pas engagé là-dedans pour taper du
du gilet jaune ou ou faire chier le
monde quoi. C'est qu'ils avaient
peut-être une volonté je sais pas ils
pensent que qu'il y a une nécessité à ce
qu'il y ait un peu d'ordre et des
garants en fait et euh Ouais il y a
Ouais. Non mais moi j'ai j'ai jamais été
aussi peu antiflic que maintenant malgré
que j'ai fait plein de gardes à vue,
j'étais beaucoup plus antiflic qu'avant
quoi. Et mais après c'est pour continuer
pour les jeunes, c'est ayez confiance en
vous quoi. Parce que
il faut Ouais, je sais pas en tout cas
de de pas de de pas rester dans dans
cette sensation d'être des merdes quoi.
parce que c'est c'est le discours
omniprésent de dire que la jeunesse, on
a rien à [__] on l'écoute pas et que
tous les gens qui sont en train de vous
faire des leçons de morale ou castrer
vos libertés, c'est des gens qui ont
[__] la planète quoi et qui ont [__]
notre monde politique quoi. Donc voilà,
essayez de vous rassembler, de discuter,
de réinventer une nouvelle gauche
peut-être ou alors de nouvelles
mouvements politique de réflexion et de
ça. Voilà.
Cédricou, merci. Merci à toi.
[musique]